foreign
[Music]
it's a beautiful summer Monday and at me
as H3 the weather announcer I'm here
today out here in Los Angeles beautiful
day out here in Los Angeles and you can
clip that screaming
and run it as my promo hope everybody
had a good weekend I know somebody who
did
Zach
by the way yeah
[Applause]
uh by the way before we get too deep
stamps.com sponsored us and I love them
for that thank you to them Zach what
happened this weekend for you I don't
know man I couldn't tell you well well
set up well explain to me how this came
to be it should be I mean you know I
mean
um so I posted a clip from the Roxy
which was in May and uh John from
Portugal the Man follows all of us he's
a fan of the show I Gotta Give a huge
shout out to John
um he commented he's like so are you
gonna come play with us at the Hollywood
Bowl or what
and I'm like are you are you serious
like we got in contact we spoke and he's
just the nicest guy and um
it came to be yeah he made a childhood
dream come true and I have to say feel
good story of the year that's right and
not only that the footage dude you are
slaying up there it's so sick it was I
am with the Slayer it was unbelievable
I'm gonna play it uh you guys can enjoy
the the rocking not them just a heads up
there is copyrighted music it did not
get claimed on The Re-Up so I don't know
if you wanna
I think it's fine okay we could talk to
him it's gonna be distorted enough yeah
we could talk to your boy
but shout out to Portugal the Man and
what was the guy's name John John in
which which position is he in the band
he's the main dude he's the singer he's
uh his name is in Portugal his name is
John Johnny Boy and then the whole just
everyone was so nice they were so
welcoming and they made the process so
easy and those guys Shred by the way too
man they're so unbelievable so here's
Zach
main stage baby Hollywood Bowl how many
is that seat eighteen thousand
that's a big audience
here it is Zach Lewis live at the bowl
foreign
were you nervous when you came out I
wasn't nervous when I came out I was
nervous like you know the anticipation
of all of it like I woke up that morning
I'm like like I gotta play the ball I
can't do this I can't do this but
um I have a lot of supportive people in
my life uh parents my girlfriend it's
salmon Ian we're so very supportive you
guys were there
oh yeah he I he was acting all nervous
before and this dude's up there Hamming
it up he was like you know had his
tongue out doing the holes right into
that [__] he's walking around the stage
yeah flipping his hair he's a total
natural this guy
and then uh Cam and love were there
everyone was the whole crew was so
supportive it was [__] amazing uh Cam
and love were there
um that's so cool it's so nice the whole
crew was just like
so unbelievably supportive it was a
great show dude yeah it was amazing dude
dude still shredding bro and you guys
are hitting like note changes and stuff
yeah there's probably about four songs
in that medley and we uh we didn't
rehearse once how did you guys hit those
those chord changes so it's just it just
came to be man you listen to this [__]
so sick Bro
is that him
no so that is uh Eric the guitarist okay
John actually walked off stage to give
me my moment oh like wow just like
what a guy amazing person
I wonder if he'd like to call in just to
talk about it I'm sure he would
I think he might be in the air right now
because I think he was flying back home
where's back home Portugal
well it may only make sense I mean
so when you went out there were you like
I got this when she started playing I
chugged the bear and I'm just like it's
go time baby that's the way to do it
dude he really I gotta say I know you
shred he'll put a lot of faith in you I
mean you delivered yeah he gave you that
Center Stage I I am just he's the nicest
person in the world he just I cannot say
it enough nice things about them dude
that is so [__] awesome
and then we went to this little thing
this was recorded by a fan by the way
they posted server they're like uh was
that [__] Zach there was a good
amount of uh foot soldiers on the
audience I love that um but yeah I I am
just beside myself it felt like a dream
really didn't sleep last night but um
still buzzing still buzzing but I I
really owe a lot of support to the whole
H3 crew and um
it was amazing here's here's I guess
another video that shows the scale did
you film this love yeah okay I don't
know if you could open it I'm trying I
gotta download it all right
here's uh some some footage love to it
shows the like how many people there is
there
massive
oh [__]
[Music]
great
that's yeah that's crazy bro it was next
level dude well well done sir thank you
very much do we have any behind the
scenes footage or anything I didn't get
any BTS footage I got a few photos but I
was just honestly I was so
I was I was nervous walking in there and
I just um
I I just I don't know what to say oh
yeah there's that picture I love this
foot
it's giving
it's that's the new kemosabe dude ready
to [__] [__] up oh dude a little more
impressive I love that porch well
congratulations thank you thank you very
much thank you hell yeah I couldn't have
done it without you guys so thank you so
fun so nice and and shout out to John
was it from Portugal the Man reach out
let's let's do a call that'd be great
thank you for being such a great guy man
he's the [__] man dude he is the man
well
um oh one thing I want to do well anyway
moving on thank you Zach
um I want to talk about something Philly
D covered on his uh show
um on
on one day ago
and uh and yeah man he just
U.S lawmakers waging a water war that
could devastate the nation or there's
such a controversy right now rather
important flight regulations
brand new Philip DeFranco show you daily
dive into the news today powered by the
Beautiful Bastard drop that goes live
tonight at midnight new and Incredibly
that Beautiful Bastard hoodies but I
don't we don't need shirts in the
Beautiful Bastard Nation at least not
ones that are buttoned up hell yeah you
sell shirts without buttons
dad hats and bucket hats a brand new
summer shorts for the pool or Beach and
our new Fantastic linen is that a little
too close to Grateful Dead the heart
with the lightning bolt
dad hats and bucket hats
no I'm not trying to give him too much
[__] yes it doesn't do that they do the
school not there right yeah right it's
totally different of course we love
summer shorts with a pool or Beach and
our new Fantastic linen button-ups and
all of it at 30 that's why yeah
merch bro guys head on over to Beautiful
Bastard get your button buttonless uh
linen teeth and then text me at
813-213-442 wait what the [__] why you
give me your number docs get it off the
screen get off the screen
Philly you're doing too much here
brother protect me the update but we got
a lot of news to talk about so so my
what I loved about this
is that this man straight up doesn't
even mention
what's going on that he's just sitting
there top open and he's feeling himself
and you know he's got it he's [__] he
looks great he looks great
looks like he got recently waxed that's
what I was gonna say not a single hair
on that yeah it's beautiful I've been
doing this for years man
no no the open shirt man oh yeah but
he's like there's no bully open you go
like a few buttons he's he's fully Zach
you're kemo sabe this is the news man
this is like CNN online with the shirt
open
he's Jeffrey tubing in it man oh no no
you're wearing pants Billy as a recorder
um he doesn't explain it suddenly hear
something that I don't think everyone
needs to be in he appears with a shirt
on it's very mysterious wait what are
your thoughts
he left the morning wait why yeah
he's letting it linger a little taste
why did he change is that curious I mean
filmed on different days I assume right
but how do you how are you gonna come
out like this and not even acknowledge
it I bet all the comments are about it
let's see
he didn't have a chance to button up his
shirt he's so dedicated to bringing us
the news wow I like that explanation wow
and so did Philly
Phil went from click baiting us with
celebrity bodies to his own
there you go what an arc there it is
Philly D is feeling himself and
rightfully so and I'm feeling myself
[__] it yeah boy is it
is it maybe to promote that his shirt
like his clothing is 30 off like
literally he's wearing it he's wearing
it 30 off
or at least say hey this is that shirt
at least acknowledge the shirt or
something smash that button smash so
here it is guys tits out Monday piss out
day and like Philly D I am going to do a
wardrobe a wardrobe wow oh no and I'm
like really D I will explain that this
is Teddy fresh you can get it
teddyfresh.com thank you
it does have buttons on it do you want
to do the episode shirtless
you know I thought he should but he he
felt he's a little distracting yeah
that's what makes it fun not sure about
it I prefer more comfortable in his
shirt not with one all right fine so uh
let's see so today we are having this uh
debate with xqc about fair use
um I know some of y'all aren't super
excited about it which I get because
he's hard to understand and
can be pretty annoying
right but uh he's the character Guy
character
but I'm gonna do my best to keep it on
the rails and to keep it tight and
succinct as possible because my goal is
to actually have a meaningful
conversation about this or we can
actually you know talk about stuff that
matters and not turn it into a a circus
so I'm gonna try to keep it on the rails
I'm trying to keep it focused
and if it just uh descends into madness
then I'll just wrap it up you know what
I mean
but I think it's worth a shot
to see uh if there's can be some uh
conversing here potentially so that's
coming up he's gonna call in at two
um
also okay this is a huge correction I
need to issue oh yeah this is big oh my
God news this is a retraction this is
Yep this is a retraction this is a
correction this is an apology to the
Streamys yep one of the greatest
organizations on planet Earth on Friday
we defamed them by showing an edited
video of their trailer for best podcast
now this was
where do we grab this from though right
so okay so
and after careful forensic analysis I
should say I do not think
that this was intentional by the user to
uh deceive us they were just trying to
show the weather they were trying they
were trying to do the old phone screen
record and as anybody who's tried that
you know you got to be pretty quick you
got to hit the recording you gotta go
hit play real quick and sometimes you
miss something well here there's a
here's what happened
I had accused the streamers of playing
favoritism of showing like obvious
intention for us not to win but here's
the actual video you guys
not only am I the first shot no I'm the
I'm the hero shot I'm the first this is
you just pulled up this is the the one
that we showed on Friday just to be
clear okay okay so well we all remember
that right it's just me talking about
the weather
so here's the full clip
check this [__] out you guys
yo 550 likes okay streamings damn let's
go
big numbers but the rip of it that was
uploaded to our subreddit I had more
outputs than that
let's go streamies
who says this isn't a prestigious award
not me I would never I would never say
that ever not my life I think I'm the
only one that actually talks about this
show to be honest creamies are the only
reliable uh Workshop yeah if I win yeah
guys if I win trust me
it's all gonna change for you guys
there's a lot of incredible
you know
honest
must-see TV
here's how it starts hello everybody do
you think he's about it's just hello
everybody wanna look happy I love jovial
and it's the hero shot frame number one
the hero shot number one money Ethan and
also that means they used mine twice in
addition to call me daddy and Logan Paul
so watch it again the whole way through
and I have to unmute it everybody
which maybe is why it was missed maybe
yeah you know I mean they just had Logan
going whoa going back to unpurposed
Jason they're obviously booting they're
building up each and every he goes I'm
Jay Shetty I have the I'm the number one
Guru on nutrition in the world here's my
guess to talk about Crystal water magic
he's a special guy by the way he had
this guest on the show that's like the
biggest broadest dumbest crap ever
he's like yeah dude water has crystals
in it that can uh
did we talk about the we never did we
never did is the water or it's not
Crystal
um structured water yeah structured
water I don't know if it's the same type
of thing do you remember this movie what
the bleep do we know it was like super
popular
when I was in college and they got the
bleep do we know I kind of remember the
name they talked about like the double
slit experiments and all and kind of
weird stuff but one of the things they
talked about is this one guy was like if
you pray over water If You Give Good
Vibes to water you can see under a eight
microscope that the crystal structures
are more pure and then if you talk [__]
to the water or play it nasty music it's
chaos yeah total [__] completely
made up trash yeah I don't remember the
movie I remember meeting somebody else
that believed in that though well yeah
it's pretty
it's I mean it's like it's something you
would find in the same Facebook group as
like a q Anon you know Crystal Water I'm
very curious to hear what uh what our
boy Martin has to yeah he I think he did
a video debunking in it did he already
yeah
okay you can pull it up if you can find
it I'm pretty sure he did though what
the bleep do we know is a 2004 American
pseudo-scientific film
that posits a spiritual connection
between quantum physics and
Consciousness yeah
on their Wikipedia on the Wikipedia page
for the film uh the film's co-director
mark Vincent would go on to co-found the
knife media approach Trump digital news
Outlet wow dude linked to Nexium dude I
was right it's part of the Q Anon
pipeline have a good night
holy [__]
dude the Crystal Water people they're
getting mainlined
I guess they think hey if we can
convince you that the water is like
it reacts to Vibes then
we can convince you that the election
was stolen why not Rotten Tomatoes gave
it 34 what the bleep yes Jim
it was a big phenomenon at the time
though
one of you here's Shetty here in Los
Angeles do you think you're still
cutting edge commentary
I don't know man
you think I don't have it still no
that's not a matter of winning it's just
a hello there you think it was
disrespectful the weather report
look I okay I'm gonna shut up
it's okay go ahead I'm here I want to
listen no I'm just saying it I should
not speak no respect man no respect but
I did get the hero shot dude yeah and I
got two clips I love the Streamys I
think I'm gonna be a streamy fan okay
streamy's forever dude okay oh he's
[__] first
Ian I have to I'm gonna message you
something
um
oh God yeah an idea for a streamy
segment I don't want to say it because
it I I don't want you guys to know about
it
okay wait why let's talk about after the
show okay we'll talk about it that's a
good idea
it's a better idea
you ever turned to Blind Eye yes
I was like I was like no it's not we
don't know what episode it is ever we've
been saying 100 for about I think 85.
man he wants you to wire him a dollar oh
I mean they didn't give a lot of respect
to Logan he's the only one that had like
a you know some meat to it I'm sorry
this is the number one podcast in the
world I think so I don't even think you
can really make a decent argument
against that no it's hello there hello
there and frankly it is a beautiful day
here in LA
right well you said it was raining in
the club right it's right it's not
raining today out here in Los Angeles
whatever I say is what goes things are
ever changing your finger is on the
pulse that's why this is the best
podcast right I know what's up with the
weather oh [__] so what do we believe do
we know guy was one of the main victims
of Nexium oh yeah he was one of the he's
the guy that made the main documentary
about Nexium oh I see he was the guy
that made what the bleep the Mark I mean
so of course he fell into a cult
seems like a decent guy though right I
mean well at least he
tried to uh
bite back at the whole thing he's the
director of uh what the bleep uh
petition for Olivia to do uh Ethan's
makeup for the Trixie
collab I would literally die or if
Trixie will come on the podcast
definitely I want to do should I do all
drag yes I think it'd be amazing for
Trixie to put you in Drag
that takes a lot of time I'm down though
I'm in I'm in couldn't be worse than the
mask right
it'll be so pretty and so so much more
sparkly I bet let's see uh I have some
health updates about myself okay
so I've got the results of my ultrasound
that I did on Saturday you're pregnant
hi
congratulations I laid on the table
like my wife does when she gets Soldier
scents for the baby same thing they
scooped me up uh-huh I always wonder why
they put the goo on there
I think
you know what I don't know it's just to
make it slide better yeah okay I thought
it maybe was conductive
I didn't know but yeah it's just a slide
better yeah I don't know so she slid
that thing all over my body dude
oh she was on my gut she was on my side
whoa dude and she looked at all my
organs
and I'm happy to say at 38 years old
that um
my organs are in good shape
and honestly that's I was really nervous
to open that
hmm
the only I guess they're the only
anomaly was that there was a tiny polyp
on my gallbladder which is normal
it doesn't need follow-up
normal ass pull-ups dude and if you guys
want to know it was
and if you guys want to know if you guys
want to diagnose me at home it was four
millimeters hmm
the size of the polyp completely normal
I'm being so upfront with you guys right
now had you teased this ultrasound
procedure on the show I think I talked
about it because thing on Friday I have
to admit I thought that this was an
update about the lupus Saga well it's
all connected oh it's all connected
that's connected to my my hematologist
ordered it for me to make sure I don't
have cancer
okay well that's good news then that is
good news that's fantastic yeah it is
good news how how's the Anna tighter or
whatever yeah how's your titers the I
haven't tested the annotider since the
first time but I'm assuming it's
probably considering the hematologist
didn't order a follow-up of that it's
probably not likely to have reduced
right but I do have an appointment with
a rheumatologist
um
I think next week yeah next week I have
a rheumatologist one and then also on
top of that
thank you to somebody in the audience
who recommended apparently there's like
a doctor in La who's like Mr Lupus
if you look at his credentials it's like
the lupus he's the president of the
lupus Association of America okay okay
well this okay he works at Cedar Sinai
this guy knows Luke he's Mr lupus so I'm
gonna go to him to get a second opinion
just to make sure whatever the [__] is
going on while Gooch's opinion may not
be the most fun
yeah
yeah and every time I talk about this
I'm reminded about Fortune I am to be
able to do all these things so if you
have medical bills that are um
crushing you or causing you problems
send it to Dan so I'm gonna pay I'm
gonna pay one of them off Don is going
to personally pay for them I'm gonna pay
for one of them I thought you were you
were like okay give it to Dan well that
happened on the stream where someone's
like you know my my on the see you next
Tuesday uh right did they ever reach out
you know what no huh
that's a shame I mean I actually had
several other people reach out because
of that so we'll find a good candidate
and I'll just pay their [__] off
okay that's very generous just pay it
for it a little bit you know I am very
fortunate to be able to go see Dr lupus
doctor hopefully he doesn't give me
lupus it's like you spend your day all
around lupus all day
I can give it to me I don't believe it's
contagious he's gonna come shake my hand
I'll be like excuse me oh hey hey hey
hey hey hey hey
excuse come on
some gloves on but uh actually Shredder
was
not feeling well unfortunately on the
weekend oh no he puked three times
yesterday and it was really stressing me
out honestly the whole I gotta be honest
with you guys the health stuff with
shredder and myself has been really I
guess it's been getting to me
but like the thing with shredder is just
like Ugh
I'm just so scared you know I don't know
when he's gonna just get really ill it's
gonna happen though
and so
it's like every day I'm just watching
him so closely so he's gonna come get an
IV
and uh anti-nausea
treatment
not an IV uh
intravenous flu Oh that stands for Ivy
they get big influids under his
Kim fluids they give them fluids
it's not an IV
he's turning six in a month
so young I know it's like
yeah anyway not to bring everyone down
but that has kind of been getting to me
to be honest although in terms of the
stuff with my help
um
in terms of this stuff
that um
of my health it's look it's okay you
know I haven't gotten any bad news in a
few weeks so
no news good news yeah
so um
let's see here
new leafy photo just dropped guys you
remember leafy is here nope
leafy is here remember him
um
you guys remember him
can you pull up the one where it says
new leafy would have molested old leafy
I'll show that one anyway I submit he
posted selfies uh recently and I think
it was really Brave of him you know
because everybody's beautiful and I
think it was really Brave of him to come
out and to share this and say hey this
is what I look like now and I submit
this without commentary
how old is this guy again like 35 40. I
don't know how old is Lee by the way
this caption's super dope too smoking in
hotel bathroom [__] this 11.
hour flight with layovers literally
literally smoking in the airplane
bathroom dude
this is just being lucky it's just Hotel
bathroom
well what does that mean if he's talking
about flight
he's in an airplane right yeah that
picture's in a plane so I don't
understand what he means by smoking in
hotel bathroom
did you say the AI generator one
so here he is and I mean again this is a
dude who who
this is how they've generated his whole
body yeah
oh that's awesome that actually looks so
legit even the hand doesn't look that
crazy yeah huh it's missing maybe he's
not missing finger maybe it's just kind
of pushed over this side
um
this is the guy who spent his career
like bowling people making fun of their
appearances
I believe he called me fat a few times
literally
but um anyway the point that I I am
sharing this for is simply to
say that I'm proud of him for for you
know
showing himself and saying hey this is
what I look like now it's okay to look
like this and I'm in solidarity with
everybody because everybody's beautiful
and I think that's cool that he's
changed don't you
it's Brave
the leafy on the right looks like he
would molest the leafy on the left that
is an interesting take
that is kind of an interesting take
Jesus
so I don't know you got I mean you know
I'm not I
I submit without commentary other than
to say that I'm proud of him right
so good for you buddy
keep up the good work I can see being
keemstar friends with keemstar is not
only good things for your life
same with
I'm gonna go there yeah
[Music]
oh this was pretty good yeah this this
was pretty good
although he I guess he hasn't really
changed that much these are all tweets
from
June and July
July 30th was the last one so that was
what like a week ago it says [__] trans
kids I mean that's not cool
you know pinned I see it's just [__]
up from trans rights put that out there
he's just being gay is worse than being
racist being transphobic is good he says
I am the Hitler of lgbtq he says
so I guess he's still being edgy but um
well
it's Brave of him to at least
acknowledge like hey I'm not perfect I
am making fun of trans people when they
are the most marginalized and at risk
folks in our community but here I am
here I am
it's good and it's powerful
somebody made this I don't I don't
support this frankly because I'm not
listen I'm not flaunting my weight loss
this is from the subreddit I you know
what I mean my weight loss is my own
personal journey and there's nothing I
understand that everybody has their own
personal Journey with weight
and so I can't judge anybody but I'll be
I mean obviously yeah I'm happy that
I've I've been able to achieve some of
my goals
uh leafy called me a fat disgusting
piece of crap I guess
but what's it what I find really
inspiring is just he's finally embracing
who he is
because before he would never show his
face and it's a shame to be insecure
like that right it's a shame he covered
his face he would never post selfies
and um
it's it's inspiring and touching to know
that
he's at least gained some confidence so
we love that for him
and our Metamorphoses have kind of um
coincided you might say too
he absorbed what I left behind
and that's a and that's a good thing
because I have good qualities that I
think he would want to absorb leaving my
friendships
but yeah I'm not trying to say anything
other than to say that uh we wish you
the best leafy and we're proud of you
[Applause]
we're proud of you buddy
there it is man love that kid
love ya love that kid man he's a good
dude
good
and he's Pro the thing is he's proven it
to all of us
yeah
oh speaking of uh speaking of body uh my
guy issues look at this [__] dude
this is the new Alpha meta
um
six-pack or you're fired you guys pick
this [__] out bro it's the next level
you actually don't work for us dude I
can't play the beginning of this videos
bro what are you watching why don't you
let me listen to the company my entire
team if you don't have a six-pack you
don't work for us hell yeah no I know I
know it's called everybody say standard
how about we raise them
how about we raise them wait kill us
it didn't get claimed
this did not get cleaned this did not
get oh thank you Zach yeah
but we can play our own alpha music and
I can read it okay
so here play our alpha music yeah it
seems to have disappeared what
no I mean we already watched it oh wait
no here here we go what's done is done
okay there we go
you have to hear him talking though you
know okay ready you want me to mute the
video
I guess we'll do both that'd be that'd
be good enough to confuse the algo
dude Instagram I swear to [__] man why
would I open it there
[Music]
okay we're gonna try one more time
okay I can't hear him he says if you
don't have a six-pack you're fired you
don't work for it
it's called everybody says it's called
standards
how about we raise them how about we
raise them people
how about we raise it how about we raise
them okay
how about we raised them how about we
were raised how about we raise them dude
Khaled is the man I'll call it
cappuccino dude his new meta is the best
I love them love them uh-huh
is called cappuccino
have you guys quit getting [__]
civilized get civilized you know there's
some people in this room that said uh I
would sue my my uh company if they uh
told me I had to have a six-pack we know
you would
that conversation was for the one
percentage that wasn't good bro I know
you would I'm talking to the tools and
freaks that are cool being used and
abused and treated illegally bad by
their bosses I'm talking to the people
that I that promise me they won't sue me
for abusing them in the workplace
it's so Alpha bro
this guy is less than six months away
from being arrested for human
trafficking
that's a comment so good guaranteed full
head of hair or you're fired
that's some very my wife left me my kids
won't talk to me kind of uh energy
look how hard his nipples are holy [__]
he's probably roided up too yeah those
are the red nipples aren't they so there
you go I mean the alpha sphere is really
evolving
clearly leafy is not yet joined their
ranks but I think it could do well for
him
but uh who knows he's doing very well we
love him okay let's thank our one
sponsor
that it's almost time to
hop on the call excuse me
your excuse it's all good
love ya with xqc
no homo
so that being said Thank you to
stamps.com
oh aim
we love stamps.com
legitimately I do love stamps yes um
stamps.com is one of these businesses
that you're gonna wonder why haven't you
been using this before legit
like if you mail stuff
a small business a large business or
just personal stuff that you're mailing
a lot
stamps.com is going to revolutionize
your life it's going to make your life
easier it's going to save you money
simple as that I mean these guys have
been in business for 25 years serving a
million businesses
here's how it works they send you a
digital scale
you weigh your package or envelope
whatever it is you're mailing
you get the exact weight and then you
print the label you put it on it then
you can have them come to your home pick
it up or you can drop it a note you can
drop it at the mailbox you could drop it
in a Dropbox
the power is in your hands but wait
that's frankly not even the best part
not only is it more convenient
stamps.com has huge carrier discounts up
to 84 off USPS and UPS rates 84.
that's like serious serious business
there
and they're able to do that because they
work with so many businesses they have a
a large amount of negotiating power
with these carriers
you know
it's really that's what it is guys and
they're just such been such a loyal um
and fantastic sponsor I I have nothing
but nice things to say about these guys
25 years stamps.com has been
indispensable
for over 1 million business so get
access to the USPS and UPS Services you
need right from your computer anytime
day or night no lines no traffic no
waiting here's a deal for you guys
set your business up for Success when
you get started with stamps.com
today sign up at stamps.com h3tv for a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage
and a free digital scale there's no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com
h3tv H stamps.com
h3tv and thank you so much
to stamps.com consider sport uh
supporting our sponsor if you're in the
market for such a thing
[Music]
oh
so uh we have a few minutes so let's
talk about let's see what else we got
here
oh I guess I could touch on the fousey
situation just to kind of talk about
what's happening there it's pretty heavy
duty stuff
maybe you should wait for after the call
you think so maybe yeah it might end up
going like I might have more to say
about it than I think right
possibly
Gooch says Gooch says we talk about
Bella Ramsay
that's a nice little Bella Ramsay oh my
God I love her
they oh today she's a days a day yes
they use they them pronouns can I say
days a day uh
yeah they use they they them I apologies
guys you know
I'm I all respect to to them we're
relearning I'm still
I'm so Boomer I'm really trying to get
the pronouns
but I respect the crap out of
them and I think she's amazing I love
just at it again God damn it I'm so
sorry I I respect
they are amazing I don't know why it's
so hard for me you guys don't have a
problem with it right really no uh
you'll I'll just say everybody means but
I want to I want to Again Naturally
you're retraining your tongue you know
what I mean yeah
I I just I hate that it's not natural I
want it to be I've said the building
constructive
uh they I'm gonna I'm not gonna say Bell
because I wanna practice actually saying
it the right way okay
um
I hugely respect them
both in Game of Thrones and last of us
they are
so talented I've been a huge fan
when I saw Bella in Game of Thrones you
know I didn't even realize it was the
same person at first that was in Last of
Us
but I'm pretty young because I mean that
was shot right that was like five or six
years ago now but Bella had such a
standout performance in Game of Thrones
I remember talking with Ila about how
good
they were
at the time
so big shout out to Bella Ramsey who was
spotted at Teddy fresh hoodie okay let's
go family potentially potential family
looking incredible Bella Ramsay in
recent Tick Tock from August 5th reach
out girl
uh
oh [__] I mean Reach Out
to be fair it's like girl like this
sometimes I call like sister I call you
girl it's girl like this kind of girl
yeah can you show me yeah it's like this
yeah is that okay
[Music]
probably not right now when you're
trying to implement that they them
specifically you know so but reach out
or we'll try to reach out as well
because I'd love to hook you up with
more
Teddy fresh and I apologize for getting
your pronouns wrong I hope that uh
you'll forgive me for that
so um
oh interesting you see what cam just
sent along
I was actually wondering I had the same
thought cam when I was looking at it
that those bangs are doing a lot of work
there but he's always done he's always
been a bang boy yeah Bangbus boy
and here's the thing I think the banks
look good on him so I get why he does It
Forward fair enough he has beautiful
straight black hair comb It Forward King
there you go fair enough now what it
looks like underneath the bangs I don't
know who am I to say it's not it's
important as he has beautiful hair
growing my hair back people
yeah
uh so the fousey thing I'll talk
afterwards
I'll touch on that
the kai updates I mean we maybe we
should just get it started
let's kick it off so here's semi the zoo
but I'll set up the zoo I send it to you
on uh your phone wait I hate to say this
I'm so sorry but he looks like JonTron
in this photo
does anyone else see it sure yeah
that's just what I see
okay all right guys give me a minute I'm
gonna try to set this up
you sent me the zoom link I did yeah
just hit me with some waiting music
WhatsApp I'll read uh some chats in the
meantime actually shout out to before
the show even started uh perennial uh
Hoopa Trooper favorite Bella Simmons
donated a hundred memberships oh my gosh
we hadn't even gone live thank you
with the donos so shout out to you uh
what we got here
uh Nia who is a 30 month member said
it's totally muscle memory Ethan don't
worry the more you do it uh the more the
pronoun will have actual meaning to you
uh I legit still misgender myself oh
there you go interesting well thank you
for being understanding I'm Legit trying
yeah you're clear you're trying and I
mean
people that know you know it's kind of
not your fault thing for you thank you
stumble over your words a little bit
okay I think that's fair to say right
thank you Robin
not your fault your fault uh what about
leafy does he have an excuse Robin your
fault right
he doesn't
uh let's see so I'm gonna run to the
bathroom real fast while uh xqc I sent
the link I sent it in the DMS okay on
Twitter
so hopefully somebody get lets you know
I just want to uh uh pee before we start
this I'll be right back sounds good
sounds good what else we got I mean
Ethan cares makes all the difference
there you go uh Dan is the queen says
Jack thanks thanks Jack it's true
um you can't do nothing wrong dad is
stupid oh my God this damn thing is so
annoying YouTube
fix your [__] it's flipped yo uh Savvy
said damn block me that's not true I'm
gonna do that uh 27 woo uh 20 donation
not Destiny coaching xqc on Kik for his
interview
I mean whatever that's fine you can get
coach he needs it
let's be honest uh kick it's totally
muscle memory oh right I already read
that one uh hi Ethan crew I recently
lost my 13 year old Chihuahua no I'm
sorry to hear that sorry to hear that I
love Chihuahuas I know a lot of people
get annoyed by them because they're
little nippy dogs and they can be
annoying but uh I like chihuahuas
you got hit by a Chihuahua yes I've been
bitten twice in my life one was a
Chihuahua at Petco when I was a kid and
then and then the infamous Pitbull
incident
um it's basically the two ends of the
spectrum on like danger it's true I feel
very blessed we have a uh Priscilla our
dog as a Chihuahua mix she's a Chihuahua
pug so we call her a chug chugger chuggy
little sugar little chuggy
uh let's see what else we got Dan please
what does the two on your headphones
mean uh it's just labeling the channels
that they are on our headphone amplifier
in the back no no real significance it
could be that I'm like number two his
lie it has a big significance two love
[Music]
two you say two I've been saying two
every episode I've been saying yeah make
it a point so that you come in right on
that too I'm just saying look into it
guys
[Music]
uh let's see uh Rich Lux donated 100
let's go
thank you for trying H3 to help fousey
heart growing heart well we'll uh stay
tuned because uh Ethan wants to talk
about all that but it'll be after
The Showdown The Showdown of the century
here
um hope everything's okay with you and
sweet Shredder love y'all
uh love ya there's somebody talking
about John from Portugal I first met
John and Zach wait there's a Zach in
Portugal the Man he's the bass player oh
okay in 2009 at the bottleneck in
Lawrence uh Kansas and they're the
sweetest people alive you know I've been
hearing nothing but good things about
like legitimately not just from Zach but
just in general it seems like nothing
but plus the other other Zach is CH two
oh no no oh no okay [__] that's too many
Zach's on the stage man too many John I
um hit me up to play fortnite with him
wait for real yeah I swear to God he's a
gamer yeah this is a this is a while ago
yeah because I used one of his songs in
one of my very old videos and uh yeah I
think he he was uh arlena messaged him
first I forget how it came about but
yeah he offered to play uh fortnite
Legend legend yeah Legend
uh he is
would you like me to kick it off here
I'm ready does he mind if I um chew on
this ball during the uh toxic sludge it
helps me uh it helps you concentrate my
uh fidget spinner type of thing quick
sign up my tongue was so [__] up after
Friday
yeah let's uh let's revisit that after
uh a call here the roof of my mouth was
destroyed from that here's Felix let me
baito in him and throw him up
excuse me
oh
hey Felix can you hear me
yeah you're still my deep fry bro and
also I see myself on a delay look okay
hold on one sec we'll we'll get it right
before we start okay one second Dan is
gonna uh
fidget around a little bit how are you
I'm doing good I didn't stop yet but I'm
chilling out what's up you said you
didn't sleep yet no because um I didn't
want to
okay sleep is optional for you sleeps
for the week sometimes yeah so how much
do you sleep usually in a in like a per
night average oh look at like six seven
but I just takes you a while at least to
go to sleep and when I go to sleep
otherwise sometimes I'll skip a day or
two so you can skip a day or two of
sleep and then sleep for six or seven
and you're fine
but I'll sleep like an eight after like
a church video Bender what happens is
that um
um if I if I wake up after like six
hours after that I wake up like I'm
sticky like my brain is like really slow
and foggy and it my head my brain feels
heavy right that's interesting
I think that's awesome that you can do
that I mean sleep
yeah same to be honest good for you
brother all right so is everything
looking good back there Dan or you need
a couple more minutes very unhealthy
though but do we still sound deep fried
or is it is it all good you are chilling
okay so is everything good on your end
uh Felix oh yeah I don't see any more
but yeah you don't see me anymore
oh because you guys project what I'm
talking back at me so whatever as soon
as I talk I'm back in is there a way to
change that or not oh yeah there is
there is here
I think I can fix it hold on
hold on
but it seems you guys run this show if
there's anything on the screen you don't
like it like a sponsor something like
that I'll pick it off whatever that is
because I'm just drinking like whatever
um thank you for for saying that no
you're good appreciate the thought
though yeah
uh thank you for coming you know
it's nice to uh
talk about this stuff I do think it's
important so it'll be good to have a
chat about it
that definitely is um a pretty um big
point on the internet oh it's doing it
still but uh
whatever whatever happens you're like in
the corner
um let's fix that I want to make sure
it's fixed before
I'm not gonna remove myself
Dan do you have any
he's working on it sorry just give us
one minute don't worry about it I mean
it's Zuma throne
uh
for some reason the zoom works better
with tech when it works
oh okay you think he should hide himself
yeah so he can hide his camera then
he'll just see us look at our feed can
you try that
I promise he's seeing our switch Yeah
I'm gonna have a delay oh so anytime Ian
switches he's seeing to him he's seeing
himself
for that I mean it okay is it okay
should we should we get started do you
think Dan I mean I probably need a few
minutes to fix it so if you don't want
to wait for it I I could still be
working on it while you guys start
talking for me it's fine since it's a
production okay yeah I don't as long as
we'll fix it at one point
um I'll be fine also okay somebody says
um mirrored the camera I'm not gonna do
that change the gallery I already have
Gallery we're good I think it's because
their Tech switches from the speaker
um you guys mirror back back at me very
much right
oh good
oh wait why
when I talk it shows you
yes that was what I was explaining he
just sees our feed our stream feed yeah
yeah
okay
uh oh yeah you would have to marry
yourself pretty much but otherwise it's
fine all right I guess we'll just get
started sorry about that
nobody that's fine let's just open it
like it like it's not there so I just
want to say first off like I was saying
thank you for um
doing this I think it's important
conversation to have and I'm and I think
you're you're the right person to talk
to about it
simply because I feel and I think you
would agree
with this premise that you are
you push the the the fair use value or
apparently you don't even care about
fair use at all I and I don't want to
put words on your mouth so you can
correct me where I'm wrong but you seem
to not care about it or at least you
push it as far as it can go so you seem
like the right person to talk about it
with
okay so I think there's three points to
that uh I don't want to get too debated
yet but basically
um I think I value uh
a good life product right one two um I'm
I think I'm the regular because I do a
lot of it I do good reacts bad reacts
but although I do a high density of
reacts I do a lot of it but on top of
that
um
uh against popular belief I guess these
days I
um ask for permission a lot
and I try to make an ecosystem where
things are good
and not conflictual right that's the
main point yeah okay so okay that's
that's all fair that's all good I want
to make one uh I guess I want to make
one thing clear at the top
is that I want to focus on
um
the YouTube uploads because the the
Twitch streaming itself I feel like is
too much of a gray Zone and there's
industry standard I I would be less uh I
would be more hesitant to call what
happens on Twitch
a violation of any kind so I just want
to focus on what you upload to your
YouTube channel is that okay
um okay so that's gonna be a yes and a
no because I truly believe that a twitch
as a is it someone of a competitor on uh
vods if the push didn't have vods then
that'd be wrong uh that'd be right but
twitch has Bots and all the vods stay up
and when people react they leave the
bods up it's quite the same thing as
being able to watch uh or listen to
music on stuff that remains in the body
okay that's true but just for the sake
of this conversation I just want to
focus on because like from a legal
perspective and I know you don't really
care about the legality of it and that's
fine but I just want to focus on like
the YouTube videos as they stand as like
a product I understand that the vods are
on Twitch and that that would that would
you know create an inherent problem as
well but just for the sake of the
conversation to keep things clean and uh
keep us from getting too messy that's
that's my focus if that's okay with you
okay
um you know what you know what okay
just for the sake of having a good
argument I'll do that
except for when
um except for when
the topic matters sure right it really
matters if it is an overall fine but
there are certain points that like it
plays a big role into it if it's too big
I think I want to ignore it but you know
what that's 100 fine I guess I'm just
saying that for myself so that when I'm
talking you understand that I'm talking
about your YouTube channel and not
making General statements about what's
happening on Twitch okay
yeah Okay cool so I guess my first
question for you to start is that do you
think your work is transformative of
course that's one of the main tenets of
fair use
uh do you think your work is
transformative
um yes
you do
yep here I mean okay because I I was
watching you yesterday and here you said
it's absolutely not transformative here
it is you don't have to care that's
totally fine but do you agree that uh
you've you've created non-transformative
reactions
100 yeah okay that's fine we've agreed
so here you say you've 100 made
non-transformative reactions did you
change your mind
um no no actually not I just don't mind
the the whole point is that never is a
really bad because I think we all um
have stuff that is not just one of our
if you do a a full-on yes or no I just
kind of like play with the question and
that was kind of like
so but your work is not fully
transformative some of it is not by your
own admission
okay
so so in that regard do you care at all
about like IP or copyright
or like the fact that it's illegal does
that matter if it that it might be
illegal uh does that matter to you oh no
it doesn't matter
well if flat out doesn't because well
that's fair that that's totally fair and
so because
it doesn't matter to you I don't think
it's there's any point to really even
discuss
go ahead please and open the door a tiny
bit just to give you a general angle
um
I I truly believe that usually the
people that enforce it are the ones that
have a problem with it right the problem
with the nature of the content itself
um because in terms of legality right
technically if I'm playing some Telltale
Game well I mean they could get me down
again they want right because that's
their game and I'm yanking their stuff
right so legality wise they could clap
me for everything I've got but for just
playing their game
sure yeah but obviously well so fair use
is decided on a case-by-case basis by a
judge or jury so
it's hard to do big sweeping
generalizations about what is and what
isn't But ultimately if I understand
your position you don't really care
about the legality of it you're more
like uh concerned with the philosophical
thoughts of like of uh reacting to
content
I the limitations of that is I care
enough
um enough about it to where it affects
me right so I have to care because it's
it's the legality of it right like if
somebody wants to strike down wants to
uh send out a claim whatever well I have
to act on that right so even though I
care or not that that will that will
happen and it happens all the time
except I like to create an environment
where uh I engage with people and
content that are not going to do that
because
um they believe in the mutually
beneficial nature of the interaction
such as video games even though the
video games could uh strike me and if
they want for just playing their game on
my stream right
right and so okay so I think my point is
that we can kind of skip this whole
conversation and move on to the um
because I think we both agree if we did
a fair use analysis and you admit that
when you says it's not transformative
that a lot of the stuff you do
would would fail the fair use uh test
so we're on the same page yeah and also
a lot of your stuff too so we're in the
same boat pretty much probably not as
much no
but
um by density of content but how much
you applaud as a person as a channel
I upload it this much right overall
because I have a lot of runtime you
upload about this much you were to break
down the percentage of non-centered
content your ratios almost higher is
mine I I have no idea what you're trying
to say right now
you're gonna have to unpack that more I
don't understand this much that much you
gotta explain that a lot so the content
you upload on YouTube on your channels
right the things that are on YouTube
because you don't want to Twitch talk
about my podcast
right the stuff that you you control and
upload okay yes okay sure so so overall
if you had all the content you put out
there right
I have about that much because it's a
lot of run time it's a lot it's a lot of
no [__] idea what you're talking
about do you have proof of that like
you're just saying that much this much
that seems a little silly I have the one
of the highest runtime across the
internet in terms of like putting out
content oh but fairness doesn't have to
do with how long your stream is it has
to do with your commentary on the video
if your stream is 12 hours long and
you're reacting to a eight minute video
It Doesn't Matter it matters what you
said about the eight minute video it
doesn't matter how long you stream for
so I don't understand your point
so if you if you let me elaborate on my
point instead of um breaking the
semantics right because you could you
got semantics that's how fair use works
okay
we're not even talking about the nature
of the continent yet [__] the con it
could be hold on just to be clear you
said you don't do fair use but I don't
also so we're talking about fair use
just to be clear right okay okay let's
um let's reel back a little bit and um
stop being stupid for a minute and just
kind of like listen okay I'm listening I
you said
um that I upload not to so many content
yes you said you said that too but yes
yeah yeah absolutely I'm saying yeah and
I said that you do too right and I'm
saying I
you would say oh but
but in the instance where you try to
take the high road and say well I don't
do this guys well you do and the my next
point is that an amount of content that
you upload you're non-reactive there's
actually quite a lot I don't know what
that means you have to stop saying that
it doesn't mean anything you're just
saying stuff
well I'm saying that you're you're just
doing this you do a lot of this and this
I there's no stats there's no data I
don't even know what you're referring to
I mean if you want to talk if you want
to talk about stats and data there's one
specific video that I just analyzed just
picked one out of the lot a rapper who
got a 20 Anne Frank Tattoo
let me just read off some stats and you
can tell me if mine matches up or is
worse so this is a video uploaded to
your Channel 10 days ago rapper who got
a 10 minute and frig sorry a 20 Anne
Frank face tattoo okay so the original
video is run time is 9 minutes and 13
seconds
oh sorry no the original video is 8
minutes 33 seconds okay the video here
that you up that you uploaded is nine
minutes 13 seconds that means you added
40 seconds to an eight and a half minute
video adding 7.8 run time I actually I
even did you a favor I condensed all of
your commentary on this specific video
into a into just a short video because
it's only 40 seconds so I'll show this
well this is important because what you
say the commentary does matter because
before you finish let me go so you're
about to prove me right I said I do not
transformative dog [__] and you're about
to show me nauseous on your dog [__]
then okay fair so I don't have to show
it you'll go clap me because I mean I
just said I did that okay that's like
that's like saying um I'm white and I'm
I'm on camera you said that yours is
more transformative than mine so I don't
understand the consistency or the point
you're trying to make now now that
you've brought it up I mean sure let's
look um hold on before you do that
delicious well I do think it's
interesting because the commentary music
that is pretty good actually
yes I thought they had like one song
so that's the that's the entirety of uh
the commentary you added to his eight
and and I think it's even fair and I
know you don't you don't defend yourself
on this so I guess it's kind of a moot
point but the the quality of the
commentary like you have to be
commenting analyzing uh being critical
of the content you're watching for it to
be furious but that doesn't matter right
because you don't even believe it is it
even I
you're right I think I think you got me
so I think instead
um I think we should get an example uh
one of one of your examples then sure
I'd love to let's get one of your
examples that that show me the
guidelines what I should do to react uh
how do I post that in chat can I post
this around click on that
um so instead of having my having my
example of this I think we should use
yours instead so I could learn how to be
a better Creator how do I click on that
good idea
I'd love to check it out oh I have to
open it okay I'll open it yeah it's in
the chat
uh one second here
so yeah you uploaded to your xqc Clips
Channel you uploaded uh uh
uh five dude are you so you uploaded
five well I just want to explain it you
uploaded five uh Clips or wait [__] I'm
you uploading this channel so [__] so
when it was my turn you played my clip
when it's your turn you don't play the
clip and you just comment before seeing
it no I'm setting it up for you I'm
gonna play I'm opening it here sorry
so here it is
here's one of them from your channel 1.2
million views and six no is it okay if
we watch this one
Ethan shows X you see how transformative
reactions are done number four this is
the one number four number one two three
or four yeah there's one two three four
they're all good so here it is so you
can expect hours okay Jesus finally over
Logan Paul do you notice a problem
already Felix
there's a cut here
there's okay King Jesus why is there a
cut there
huh yeah there's a cut here so whenever
you put my video or did I say wait Ethan
I think I think I've seen I've seen
something on the screen right there is
that a dead pixel is that is that just
play the [__] video bro okay but it
undermines your argument if this you're
showing an edited clip if you're cutting
out my commentary and then trying to say
I don't you do fair use it seems a
little silly but I'll play it play the
video Jesus finally over Logan Paul
apologized coffeezilla your slime is he
is a lopsided journalist with an agenda
more like an internet criminal oops
wrong video that was the first response
he actually apologized
look at this idiot yeah I mean it's not
it's not high efforts
this is not my effort I mean hold on
hold on either uh he didn't talk about
it he's literally just sitting there
quietly for the first 30 seconds you
should sue him [__] you X you see you
Thief [__] turns out it's actually on
his secondary channel so I'll play the
whole thing just let me know when to
stop
and they would be right to sue you I
think they would be in the right I I
think so thank you Paul and it's a
pretty big change in Logan's attitude so
far so let's see what he has to say to
us coffee Zilla is not a criminal
he's gonna hire me what
well you told me to let the clip play do
you want me to let the clip player do
you want me to interrupt it you got to
choose Elaine I'm trying to be I was
trying to be creative with it and kind
of do comment down at the same time and
I was trying to last night I was asking
the oldie Ethan the guy that's more of
the other buddies High roading to react
to it but he's not saying [__] says I
got a problem with it do you want me to
keep playing it or uh okay cool
that's a good one right there boy does
have some major admissions in it I want
to go through for one Logan apologizes
to me I called him I apologize my my
criticism of him right now is that he
uploaded this to YouTube
because I understand the nature of I
mean listening it goes on but I might
I'm gonna tell you I find it really
interesting that you think this is
compelling this is actually ex uh
first of all there's so many Cuts in it
it's not persuasive at all but one thing
I do want to ask you about is why you
cut out the beginning of this segment
when I talked about it here's when I set
up the video here it is and again the
framing what you say in the before and
after is really important so here's how
that clip starts Felix which you cut out
for some reason
yeah so Logan made a video after he got
absolutely bought like bought bead for
his response where he was like I'm gonna
sue you this is [__] why did you
painting me oh you played a video
oh yeah it's part of the same clip you
just went in and took out like 30 second
slices from it so basically what they're
saying is that you're going to the bar
right and this part is like where you
get in and where you get like a beer or
something like that right and the rest
of it you just [__] say [__] just
busy it's like the intro so if you put
an intro you're good to say guys you
guys and you don't understand how fair
use works and I and that's fine but I
don't know why you want to debate fair
use when you don't care about it yes
what you say in the beginning matters
bro you you're analyzing I'm
contextualizing I'm criticizing I'm
analyzing it that's what fair use is I'm
transforming it I'm not just sitting
there and the audience isn't just
watching the video while you know you
you I mean you do get up and go to the
bathroom a lot uh so I know that you
want to so but that's but that's fine
because you you don't care about it but
for you to think that this is so if you
use meth an example for your identity
Felix I don't do you think this clip is
compelling do you see what I'm saying
that this example is really dishonest
okay so in that clip my uh my editor
edited you your own word saying oh can I
ask you something your editor did this
have you watched it
um well yeah I watched it like you just
said you did oh you just watched it for
the first time so so the cuts have you
watched the unedited version on my
podcast
um yeah it's okay so then why was this
removed
if you don't let me talk I mean we're
not gonna have a conversation well I
just want to get I just want to get to
the point you know I mean because I
don't want you to deflect I want to know
why you cut this part then when you ask
a question you have to wait for me to
answer otherwise it's not gonna work and
you said okay go ahead please you did
three times that's okay go ahead um okay
so there's four there's four of them out
of many of them by the way there's we
only uploaded four because we didn't
want you to go crazy with the dmca stuff
um basically it's pretty much a lot of
it is spliced as back to batch so yeah
yeah there is a cut but yeah it's like
it's like you're pausing a video but
it's the same thing you go and started
the two and a half three that have
improving that but here's what here's
what I will say go get the one from uh
um meat Canyon that one is you okay yeah
you can't you combo
um mustache twiddling it hair and neck
skin and you do like this
you understand this concept because you
talk about all the time me Canyon is my
friend who gave me permission to react
oh oh so it's about permission then so
now sometimes hold on it is hold on
before we move on I just want to make it
clear that when you're accusing me of
not adding enough commentary that you
did upload a clip that's deceptively
edited and I mean frankly dishonest why
did you cut this beginning part okay so
Ethan Ethan why did you cut this
unfortunately the problem that I have
right now is that you're saying that now
when you're seeing all this this
whatever right but it's quite literally
you in the video that's that's edited
that says in it it does it's not the
video how is if there's Cuts in it how
it is how is that a representation of my
analysis all right examine exhibit B the
meet Canon one day I already told you I
had permission
okay okay so why do I need to look at
that so now it's about permission on
this one aspect yeah in the video You're
trashing me you say he's sitting there
for 40 seconds without talking that's
what that's one of your major concerns
or criticism it's why it's highlighted
watching the video but that's the that's
a big hit easy to do at me and I'm sure
examples of you multiple times where you
go not only 40 seconds you go two
minutes so here's talking it so then so
then I don't have to argue against you
you have to argue against yourself
because these are your own words well
you can watch your own video here's what
I'll say about that right right you're
right because the 42nd thing is not a
good analysis that's not a good that
wasn't a good thing I said because when
you're considering fair use you you can
consider even the totality of it take it
back in
no you're you still are a Content thief
in my opinion
ticket no you why would I take it back
because if you're gonna reel it back and
say I no I just said that wasn't a good
analytical point I still think you're a
Content Thief okay but so take back what
you said then why I believe it I know I
am I apologize for the 42nd thing I
don't think it was a good analysis
okay you want to go with the other
commands that you made or not huh you
want to go with the other comments that
you made or not which comments we could
go through all of them because you're
wrong across the board so every behave
every Behavior you call me Adam you have
done it in those videos okay if you say
so but why why do you want to don't okay
hold on let me ask you a question why
does that matter why does that matter
okay because um earlier uh you said it
do you care about this all the time not
all the time and they give you an answer
you were like got him he said it she
said all the time when you seem to be
the guy who doesn't do any stealing or
thieving and I have four examples right
there and you did not show an example
well then then get get another one then
well that's not my job you're the one
that's trying to prove it why the [__]
should I go pursue and try to prove I
don't do fair use that seems stupid wait
that seems like that's exactly is that
what you guys have been doing on Twitter
and whatnot right this is your whole
concern yeah I'm feeling stuff about you
not telling you to go find a video of
yourself not doing fair use that's
moronic so you said Thief right yeah
show me one I just did with the Anne
Frank one you did 44 seconds of
commentary on an eight minute 30 second
video okay where you offered no critical
analysis and you don't have permission
did you have permission for that yeah
maybe maybe I didn't so why don't you
tell wait why won't you tell me did you
or didn't you well I'm just saying are
we moving a couple are we moving the
goal post there now it's not a goal post
it's just another facet of the
conversation it's not a goal post it
quite literally is when you make it a
goal post okay I do want to talk about
the permission thing okay
I do want to say one thing
in my career in my 10 years of career
I'm sure that there's been times where I
have I've done a less good job of
reacting fairly to content I'm sure of
it right then you're not anymore and
that's something I acknowledge and
something that I'm always working on and
analyzing and thinking how I can do it
better it's something I I really care
about and the reason why this
conversation is interesting is because
it's something that you don't care about
and I'd like to know and I'd like to
understand that but are you saying have
I ever done a bad reaction in my whole
career yeah Pro yes probably almost
certainly so so then would you agree to
eat Old Ethan or not too old is a thief
sack a dog [__] [__]
uh sure yeah in those if if that's what
happened in that time sure I was a dog
[__] sack whatever the [__] you said
have you made any efforts to repair
damage or the things that you've stolen
from the people that you seeds from well
again I don't have specific examples
there's nobody that's approached me so I
it's yeah have you taken accountability
the same way you want me to get a
accountability publicly for that I just
did didn't I
no not really why not I just said yeah
I've probably done that what do you want
me to do you're gonna rob a bunch of
people and say it guys I might have
robbed somebody low foreign
well it's not like going in a store and
sticking somebody up fair use is
interpreted by judge or Jerry so is it
is it is it the forza not thief because
the way I see it the way you do it I
think is that steal something from
somebody right there's gonna be a
process of like finding who is guilty
how much and there's a whole process
behind it like the legal system is just
like I mean don't you have a legal
system you see if you have a DMC a lot
right so being a thief surely you're
going to care about that a lot so did
you damage them did you talk to them did
you make it I don't know
or if there are any all right let's move
on we're talking in circles a little bit
we won't talk about the permission thing
sure I mean so what you're doing is
pretty much you're not we're not running
well no you're not running a direction
and you're going straight forward that's
what's going on right now that's clearly
not the case but I'll I'll I will just
let it be for the sake of continuing the
argument
yeah you do it every single day I mean
I've done it maybe a few times in my
career I've done you know and again I
don't know who the victims are and if
they come or nobody's ever come to me
has anyone ever complained that you
stole their videos
um anybody that has anybody ever oh
absolutely 100 okay because nobody's
ever complained to me about that
oh so now you care about Rather somebody
right well and if they didn't tell me
well you know what we're saying the
victim of the crime doesn't matter which
is exactly what you went after me
well he's acting he's asking after the
fact that he's the exact argument that
you went at me for and you're running
away from it I don't know listen the
proof that you have victims is literally
just concrete proof you did it that's
the only reason I'm saying it I don't
understand your point so when we say
victims I said yeah some people you
stole from
their victim so okay what about your
victims I don't know who they are how
many times do I need to say that me
reaching out and making an agreement
with them and every time
yes we I you're not okay it wasn't even
if you want to be if you want to open up
the chat and go with the logs I have so
many logs to make your heads let me ask
a question I have over I have hundreds
of emails sent people more than any
reactor which is more than your friend
Hassan he does way less asking than I do
why are you bringing up a song what does
that have to do with anything because
whenever he was on your podcast he was
sucking his balls out well that's right
Mr chair reacts and uh dude you're so
dishonest you don't you don't even know
what you're talking about last week I
chewed him out for an hour to the point
where I had to apologize because people
were mad at me you literally don't know
that sounds like your problem it is my
problem but you're not you have no
consistency what you're talking about
you just said I lick his balls and now
consistency you're not making no sense
bro so what do you mean it's my problem
piece of shits for doing chair react
when he does all right because he's in
trainingly Dumb let's just move on to
the permission part you know you know I
don't you want to [__] keep doing it
Sprint let's just keep running this is a
marathon me and you how about that
we're running a straight line
right now I'm running after you and you
are going straight forward now okay good
I mean that's the point of the
conversation right let's just keep going
how what percentage of people would you
say you get permission from
um the majority
because the way it works for me before
we reactive the main lines most content
that I like I have it all lined up right
so people that I really like
the best um we uh we reach out to them
and we create this little
um kind of partnership right and when
there's a smaller Trader that's going to
be way more careful with um the amount
of growth that they're getting
um how many subscribers that they have
and I try to I try to be um better with
it and quite honestly when it comes to
small creators I've never had any
pushbacks right so no victims in that
case okay that's that's perfect have you
heard of a guy named Vince Vince vintage
you reacted to two of his videos this
one was from a month ago stolen airplane
you remember this video
uh disappearance of FBI's Most Wanted
six-year-old xqc reacts this is from a
month ago that was two and a half months
two and a half weeks ago okay perfect so
it was very recent
so so would you consider this guy a
small Creator he doesn't have a lot of
Subs
uh in fact here's his original video
flying in a store he only has four
hundred thousand well that's not small
but anyway you did this recently do you
know who that guy is
uh yes okay why didn't you ask him for
permission
um I don't know did he did he complain
because I at this point I don't know if
I have a victim right I don't know so I
didn't do it well you do actually and
what's funny is I literally just reached
out to one random person from your
recent reacts just one who followed me
because I just wanted I just wanna it
was only one for sure yeah no I swear to
God
are you a victim by the way hold on this
is important this is this is important
for you to understand
so I reached out to Vince vintage and I
said hey I'm just curious did xuc got
permission and I'm going to read you the
message he sent me if that's okay go
ahead he said really appreciate you
reaching out Ethan I've never been
contacted by xqc at all for any of my
Iraq videos my personal take is this I
love big streamers watching like xqc
Hassan misk if most critical watching my
videos on the stream it's a big ego
boost but when xqc does it it's
different when he watches my video he
always re-uploads the whole thing on his
YouTube channel with his insightful
commentary as wow chat isn't this crazy
compared to when Hassan watched my stuff
he shouted me out and he says he loves
my stuff and he sent a bunch of
subscribers to my channel a fair
exchange here's a video he showed me a
video of of Hassan doing that and then
he said xqc he really just steals my
[__] entertains his audience off
hundreds of hours I put into my videos
while I get just a link in the YouTube
description the problem isn't the
reacting it's the re-uploading of my
video with his face on the thumbnail and
also and and I don't dmca him because I
don't want the TR the Twitter drama
oh
he doesn't want the Twitter drama wait
why are you well hold on this guy says
you stole a [__] why are you denigrating
that I think you should take this
seriously well because one he's a paid
actor right I think well I mean it's not
exactly I mean that's a paid actor 100
wait what what did you say
oh it's a paid actor
he's he's a paid actor yeah it is what
it is okay well just assume for the sake
of the conversation that he's not a paid
actor
yeah okay so the first guy you reacts
right the first guy you sent a message
to sends you a paragraph looks like the
Bible right and it's stroking your ego
out but you know what that's okay all
bites I'll bite no problem yeah just um
yeah so what's what's really cool about
this right is that we can make that type
of type of international have with this
person and make it 10 times better
um for our um ecosystem right of uh I'll
have what I watched what I upload if he
had asked what he doesn't have to if he
can use a dmca system and maybe there
will be Twitter drum or not we usually
we never made we never make drama for
against yourself but then I don't know
what you're talking about dude why are
you not responding to his accusation he
says you're stealing his [__] let me
elaborate let me love it I don't know
okay let me elaborate them he he would
he would be a data outlier a person who
doesn't like it and we can either
recurve that make it better and I will
de-vanage him for every dollar that he
has lost to me right and he had
analytics to back up how much the video
uh on YouTube
um cannibalized his of any sort of um
damaging data or stats behind it I would
be more than hell I would be more than
happy to give him 10 times a 10x
whatever he'll reach out have you ever
paid anybody 10x before has that ever
happened we we have been that many times
whatever it arises if how many times
does it happen
oh I have to check with editor but it's
right not a lot I'd assume not a lot of
people do that oh okay so the amounts
really um is what you're looking at then
that no just the amount of times that
people actually take you up on that
because what you're saying is I'm gonna
steal your stuff and I don't care if you
have a problem with it you can come talk
to me like that's not that's not your
right shouldn't you apologize to Vince
it's not his job to come ask you for for
reparations for you stealing from him
don't you understand that so what you're
saying is that you went digging for
victims I literally messaged one dude
okay so nobody in your production room
why don't you just apologize to Vince
vintage
uh I absolutely will and I feel I didn't
get a Twitter DM I didn't get no I
didn't get nothing I feel really bad you
don't know why because all about the oh
the whole sphere of this everything
around it is to make something good
happen right and that matter [__]
bro nice try you literally do it to
enrich yourself you're a
multi-millionaire and you still called
them from small creators and you don't
give a [__] about their rights or what
they want and then your only
justification is oh yeah you can come
chase me down and complain and try to
get my attention so I can pay you for
the [__] I stole it's total [__] bro
you're not creating anything big for
anyone you're just taking attention and
views for yourself and you don't give a
[__] about the the uh the consequences
of that it's not your decision to make
that for other people's property
you sound like um Robin Hood or
something are you like some sort of hero
something like that because it seems
like you do a lot of that
you take the high road on that one
that's that's my point you have done
that you do that you haven't done that
okay fine I did it you know what I mean
it's like so stupid what is it it what
does it because you can't use me as an
example for your own thing because you
keep saying that you're doing it you're
doing you're doing it you come here you
call me a thief piece of [__] when
you're doing it you haven't proven that
I don't know why you keep saying that oh
oh let me send one dm I will guys I'm
going to send one message and I he will
uh automatically give me a uh full
response right now give me a minute for
it okay
you're making fun of this message I got
from Benjamin which is a genuine
expressing himself genuinely and he was
disturbed by the way he uses content can
I ask you another question
I'll take that right now I will give you
every penny yeah that I'll say this
ecosystem right but that doesn't work
for you let me ask let me ask you a
question this is the video and you do
this all the time you'll agree you st
you use the exact title and the exact
thumbnail the only reason for anybody to
do that is to confuse search and
Discovery and cannibalize views from the
original that is the only reason to do
that
do you have any sense to back it up
because I have the size of the opposites
dude it's the the thumbnail and the
title don't you see that users will be
confused
let me do something don't you think so
my YouTube channel does not grow it
quietly doesn't but you're thinking
that's because you just post a ton of
[__] there no you don't put any effort
into it okay and why do you think that
is because you don't give a [__]
okay clearly so gotcha so these are cut
Downs for the people that we call the
YouTube frogs that are just watching my
[__] um they got your content though you
don't get that right okay well same goes
by student no you haven't proven that
you keep saying that but it doesn't mean
anything okay then show me proof you ask
for permission and we got it
why now you're asking me to show you
proof dude you're absurd why is it why
you you think it's crazy dude the fact
that you're using the same title and the
same thumbnail is so parasitic it's so
shady you you are only doing that to
siphon off views and confuse people
there's no other reason for that why
would you use the same exact title and
the same exact thumbnail explain that to
me so are you more upset about the title
about the kind of the video itself well
it's the intention dude it's all it's
all together you're you're intentionally
confusing people to click your videos
since since you're all about legality
you would understand it intention is one
of the hardest things to prove out there
right I'm talking about philosophy we
already moved past legality you don't
care about fair use
just answer the question why did you do
that why did you give it the same exact
title and thumbnail just answer that oh
because I wanted to why did you want to
oh because I wanted to why did you want
to
because the thumbnail is good and it
gives the viewer uh what they want right
which is the original video they want
the original video
okay so the okay so I'll tell you since
since you you don't like questions I'm
just going to give you a fact then right
um people that don't watch react content
do not get served react content if
somebody wants to watch us you can
reacted them
oh well I thought it being cannibalistic
was a problem with you well is it not
you're gonna try to say that the Google
algorithm is somehow running D for you
that's crazy it's stupid so so you're so
you said it's cannibalistic I give you a
hint on the white snots
so if you want to just keep going back
and forth and say not there not there
not there
no no okay
and if you added 20 seconds of
commentary to his video and you use the
same title and the same thumbnail you
don't see any problem with that uh no
okay there it is so so it seems like
yeah
so it seems like you don't care about it
seems you don't not just care about the
law it seems like you don't care about
uh people's artistic creative uh
property at all it seems that you don't
have any respect for property at all
ideas it seems like it
um nobody to my knowledge has a problem
any of my videos being up right now but
you're like a prolific Thief you could
say oh I found one example of you doing
this back in to whatever year your
prolific Thief dude you do this every
day multiple times a day on your YouTube
channel
gotcha so I I will go to somebody's
house and say uh uh take something and
he doesn't care right he surely doesn't
and never never reached out and you go
out there and you go and seek the
victims out right and you failed to um
to establish a pattern of them being
cannibalized the way this is just one I
mean one is enough isn't it
okay in that case it puts the burner of
proof on you as well then that's
permission yes because I I think I I
don't need permission to transform
content dude
okay so
um one of the videos that that I have
but there's four advantage you guys tell
all of them
um if you have if you have Prof your
aspirations to any of those you win by
Landslide why would I need proof to
transform a video oh I mean the only one
is me candy because he's my buddy
there's obviously ones where like it's
obvious we're your buddies I actually
did ask me Canyon oh it's obvious so if
you understand that on Twitch too
there's people that everyone's friends
with and like but but but this guy you I
mean Vince so
so you're making assumptions about me
but we're not going to make assumptions
about an assumption I have a literal
[__] message from the guy you stole
from it's not an assumption it's
literally a fact okay so the whole
reason why this debate was in the first
place is that people were finding
victims that didn't exist they're saying
a problem for people okay okay so you
found a person who doesn't like it yes
and there's multiple um ways out
actually he even specifically named you
as the problem he said the other people
actually clouded me up where xqc
completely stole my [__] at a no
valuable commentary and then Stole My
Views that's specifically what he said
actually okay so
but there's a problem instead of
reaching routes in any way should
perform
um he waited for you to the savior of
the earth to come in and just Robin Hood
and just be it guys I got you bro why
do you really not understand the concept
that small creators wouldn't want to
start [__] with with xqc one of the
biggest uh with the craziest fan base in
the world like is that really a foreign
idea to you that they wouldn't want to
deal with this power Dynamic like you
would crush them if you said anything
your fans would harass them into
Oblivion that's too foreign for you to
understand
so this guy
um
foreigners that's about to [__] die
from something Ethan is here for to save
the day this person will now be able to
afford some food
well I'm just saying because if you want
to make a porch if you need to draw a
picture on who this person is and you
say small Creator like struggling and
whatnot he I'm saving him and you're
just moving right you are
misrepresenting so he doesn't matter
not in the capacity that you're trying
to paint which is what I don't
understand what you're saying a small
struggling Creator somebody please help
this person because those out of
business
that well no I didn't say any of that
well that you did you you did you just
actually quite literally did not say
that you said small Creator that's
enough let well okay I was upfront about
his sub count I looked at it uh but
anyway let's see I mean my bad I was
just wrong I was just a mega wrong
um
this entire time it's fine all right so
yeah I'm sure you're you're familiar
with this thread because he actually
gave you permission to perform this
analysis internet Arc uh uh uh arcanus
archivist he said Alexa he said I let xq
xqc repost a reaction to see the impact
it had okay and the analysis is
basically the video witnessed an 87
decrease in Impressions on the day of
the re-upload okay and the video also
witnessed a 52 decrease in viewers on
the day of the re-upload uh and uh let's
so so I mean of the evidence that I've
seen then it actually shows that it has
either a negligible or potentially even
a negative effect on the original video
okay so and actually he even made you
change the title and the thumbnail so
why do you think he asks you to do that
xqc
he said don't use the same thumbnail and
title why do you think he asked you that
because as a uh creator of the IP that
you'd like to [__] say because you
siphon views from people dude it's so
[__] obvious why you do it you ask a
question and you answer for me you can
have a monologue if you want to just
mute me and just go on the [__] rant
but if you want to ask me a question you
have to answer this isn't the answer
um here's the answer you can chose the
IP he wants to be different right and he
wants some changes and he
um he spoke to us right so instead of
instead of crying and being a little
[__] it seems like this Vince is crying
and being a [__] is that what you're
saying that's what I said where's my
mouth I don't know who you're talking
about is this is this Twitter or what I
know I don't mean I'm just wondering who
you're talking about go ahead okay
um
so then for them
um like I said I was saying
in fact being a little [__] ass right
at least you understands at least
there's some positives to it if not a
lot of positives and some of them can
actually do better right didn't show any
positive
okay if it was only negative she would
have asked to stick it down and would
have done that right no he left it up
for the experiment and he said do not
use any of my other videos without my
permission he literally told you that so
it's a social experiment at this point
it's like a it's like an expert so now
now it's the guys have experiments and
it's he's only letting him because it's
an experiment now okay well I showed you
proof it had a negative effect do you
have proof and not a positive effect no
you didn't no what you absolutely did
not absolutely not so sure it starts
again sure
so explain how this is good he said um
I'll let you describe the video witness
an 87 decrease in Impressions on the day
of the re-upload so
explain that dub to me go ahead
um do you in your possession had a time
machine
answer the question
you do not
um since we're gonna do the whole I'll
answer for you you do not have a time
machine right
um it is impossible to know how the
viewer would have performed and how it
went down in this its natural curve over
time right with I watched it that's an
assumption you have no proof
so one data sets right you have no data
set at least I have a data set oh my God
and also you're the dude stealing
content so the the onus should be on you
to prove the great benefit of it you you
okay we're saying okay I find it a
little bit dishonorable and a little bit
um disappointing that in the middle of
it about analytics you're a spewing
words or your audience in mind about uh
Miss stealing and whatnot when we're
trying to to prove that it quite
literally doesn't help anybody you're
mudding the waters on the results please
could you stop please seriously I mean
it's gonna get really bad I don't want
to do like the whole insult add-on thing
because you're doing that
it's just a statement of fact so um okay
I mean okay so as we go forward you are
[__] bald you're very bold you're
evolving your hair's thinning and it's
great which is it means that you're old
as [__] got it okay shall we continue
this is faulty my friend is this fun I
have a beautiful hairline Baldi is this
one for you or not
I'm having trouble with the premise it
it has a striking resemblance to you
trying to argue other points it
literally has no premise at all that's
no basis you're just you're just
throwing insults for this go ahead I'm
gonna be quiet I'm gonna sit I'm gonna
pack I'll sit away okay thank you yeah
okay
so I don't know if there's any any um
statistical analysis in the past enough
maybe I had a stat classes
go ahead yes
do you have any experience do you have
any experience with Statistics or not go
ahead just just make your point what
does it matter okay okay the curve of
the video and on how it performs that
looks like a natural curve right you can
see it's already going down before I
watch it and it keeps going down at a
certain rate
um past it right
do you have any proof or um any
indicators that the video would have
performed poorly or better
um after the reaction
so obviously the any data that we do
have which is of course just one
definitely proves that if it did have an
effect it's negative or negligible and
as the guy who is try I mean right
I mean you certainly can't say that this
helped the video so are you actually
arguing that if 87 decrease helped the
video at xqc that's really what you're
arguing to me right now that's awesome I
did so so we're going to go ahead and
have the conclusion that you did not
have a statistics class at all I
understand your point but like but it's
it's not making any sense and how is it
that a 52 decrease in viewers is a dub
for you
um because it could have been a um it
could have been five percent decrease
right right it could have been worse
yeah it could have been worse but okay
do you have any proof that it um that it
would have been or it would have been do
you have any did it behind that or not
that's I mean did of that that that's
such a silly way to try to deflect from
this really compelling data because in
my data sets I have a lot of this a
bunch of
Bunch have been looking for any excuse
any out to justify you stealing content
from people even in the face of data
that suggested here it comes when the
man fails to compile that properly
conclusion based on a one piece of data
that you don't even understand is this a
voice it's a perceivable for you or not
is this a way to you to argue and have
that conversation or what's going on
here I don't get it me neither dude
you're trying to tell me that of a
significant decrease in views is a dub
Ethan I don't mess with you I just lost
16 viewers since you've talked clearly
uh you're robbing me Eddie you know that
you're not boring maybe you're the
[__] boring one
oh you're saying it's impossible to know
because we we only have one I know
you're you're definitely more boring and
not as fun to watch
well that really
um that's a joke of course I think
you're very entertaining you're very
talented well thanks John
um so I'll say this uh
foreign
ultimately uh I'm I'm pretty perplexed
by this this conclusion that I guess
negative data even just one data set
okay I got you you know what dude you
want you want to go I really didn't
think you would buy it on a data thing
because you were gonna get [__]
clapped right but since you want the
data okay I mean even though you're the
one has to prove something that's
negative I can oh before you do that can
you do me a favor read number three of
his stipulation
this is one of his stipulations
use different thumbnail for excuse
imagine video my video and minimize I'm
sorry I'll read it because with peace
and love I don't think many people
understood that use a different just
just being fair use a different
thumbnail for xqc's reaction video to
prevent any direct competition with my
video and to minimize viewer confusion
direct competition viewer confusion even
he thinks so that's why you use the same
title and thumbnail bro why are you
denying reality
well that valid accent I just lost
[__] 16 views again holy [__] it's
kind of crazy better be funny or
something bro well I'm just telling you
yeah it's harder excuse me the way it
says you bro Hey listen you're the guy
who sits like this in [__] 22 and it
doesn't Okay so
the transformative nature is is about
how how straight you sit got it oh Ethan
you want to talk about amount of
transformation then if we want to move
on to that topic let's just get some of
your uh your I think your wife's old
merch right which is like oh yes
I saw that oh I've seen it and some of
the arguments some of the arguments he
had against it oh my God I think I
changed the angle by 16 degrees and I
changed a little bit of the gamma color
on this one that's very transformative
okay Ethan I'm gonna watch your entire
thing in not react and engineer should
perform I'm gonna change the color of
the gamma and opacity and I'm gonna
rotate it sideways that's gonna be
transformative right
Ethan gone so let me ask you let me
before I address that and I'm happy to
I'm gonna address everything you said
about Teddy fresh go ahead
what does it matter if I'm a hypocrite
how does that affect this conversation
we're having
genuinely because we're talking about
the philosophical nature of taking
people's videos right and I'm having
this conversation with you but instead
of answering the question you're
constantly deflecting to prove that no
I'm a bad guy and I don't see how why
you would do that other than the fact
that you don't have a good argument to
argue the substance like why do you keep
deflecting what does it matter if I'm a
hypocrite Ethan you know sometimes you
you said you send it like a tweet and
people still uh if you'll comment in the
bottom and say there's still time to
delete this
um if anything there's still time to
[__] end the call and you go about
your day okay before you say some really
[__] dumb [__] okay when you're out
here saying what does it matter I'm a
hypocrite I'm just saying we say well
dude um what's the matter that I'm a
hypocrite well no I'm genuinely curious
but I'll answer the teddy first before
you do your mom's credits all your
points it makes you look no it doesn't
no I'm genuinely curious
no I really want you to answer the
question and you fell on your face flat
now it's time to lay on the back no it's
an interesting philosophical question
right okay first of all the teddy fresh
thing so Teddy fresh is a company with
30 employees and by the way I love
whenever someone's losing a debate to me
they bring this up it's literally the
lowest hanging fruit and if you know
anything about me you know I've talked
about this a thousand times but I'll
address it because you brought it up go
ahead we have like a whole team of
designers and sometimes our designers um
are are taking stuff way too close to
the source and I agree and it's not okay
give a [__]
editors which makes us about equal on
that topic so you can still sometimes
when
you confused at the company when one of
the Sweatshop guys gets it gets it wrong
hold on my bad but when my editor gets
the wrong one oh no we're we are
thieving hold on hold on let me finish
my point yeah bring out Hela hey bring
him in hold on hold on hold on hold on
let me finish hold on hold on your
husband is bald
my husband looks awesome dude my
hairline is you really okay dude the
fact that you're coming for my hairline
just proves how [__] delusional your
whole that's a metaphor for your all of
your arguments okay Teddy fresh we have
designers right and it's a big we have a
fairly large company this is a common
problem in all streetwear we've had
designers who who have pretty much close
to stole designs we fired people over it
and every time it comes up we have
company meetings and say guys this is
unacceptable if you're caught doing this
you will be fired and we've made a
strict guideline and it doesn't happen
anymore it hasn't happened what have you
done to prevent it okay so okay you okay
you done okay that's what you sounded
like
is it done or no he's done you can talk
he's done I'm just being silly go ahead
I'm sorry I don't know how you put up
with this [__] I would [__] leave his
ass uh bro I'm having a third child with
him
wait XC didn't even say we're getting
divorced yet
go ahead excuse me you know you know our
four-year-old though would love your
giraffe I don't know who you got it for
but our four-year-old would love your
giraffe in the back don't buy it if it's
it's what's your pricing for no reason
it's uh but I don't get a lot okay okay
so let me let me just sorry Sheila came
to defend Teddy fresh because you're
talking about I actually wasn't planning
to come in but you brought up that
refresh listen then talk to me because
I'm the person running Teddy fresh not
him yes you want to talk about it talk
to me I understand hila okay and the
reason why I brought up that point okay
is that sometimes some things happen or
some it's something if somebody else's
fault it's a mistake it's a whatever
right and something is just gonna happen
right it's got a human human nature
and that's [__] and the question is
what do you do about it yeah what are
you doing about it on a daily basis I
took action about it yeah and it's not
it hasn't happened
online people pointed out to us we had
meeting we had meetings at the office we
made guidelines when we work with new
girls what are you doing about it that's
the question what are you doing okay
okay so if you guys stop bombarding and
you actually listen to them
just answer the question you don't need
to do these you these like if you'll
stop interrupt just answer the [__]
question bro nobody cares
all right I I okay I'll answer the
question okay
um so what you what you were agreeing
with me is that sometimes right there's
gonna be a mistake there's gonna be
there's gonna be something that somebody
doesn't wants to deal
go on go on and you will Rectify it
after the fact in hindsight correct
yes what we did is not okay you continue
to do it on a daily basis several times
it would be different if I came here and
I said I don't care there's nothing
wrong with it I'm Distributing to those
guys who made the original graphic I'm
making their life better while I'm
sitting in a Gucci shirt you know okay
um yeah that was like a thousand bucks
it's like this
um
exactly
um which I don't know why you would
bring that up to be honest that's gonna
you don't think I thought it was a good
point because you're taking because
you're saying okay somebody listen
answer the question you do nothing to
rectify it while we do so go ahead what
are you doing about it on a daily basis
every single person that has brought a
negative point about the videos
well absolutely you literally said I
don't care
oh yeah but I still do the right thing
though which is what right
which is work to make better thumbnails
better description and to better work
with the creators that are behind the
video so that we don't [__] them over
and they actually gain something from it
now I'd like to talk about Sheila for a
minute so what you're saying is that
you're repairing from hindsight which
something that even trying to get it get
at me at right and then you brought the
fact that we have 30 employees they help
us out okay fair enough then I X you see
or whatever the the corporate company a
parent company is right
um well we only have like two employees
two editors right and help us out guys
look this is so sad that we have two
guys who are playing the victim card
here right
um well they sometimes make mistakes too
right that wasn't a long long time since
we took action this just happened to you
on a daily basis just I think the
difference if I can say is that I've
been listening
and when Ethan is asking you about this
for example if you don't say that this
is wrong use the thumbnail the missing
time the matching thumbnail and title
you say I did it because I like it no he
says they're working on better
thumbnails so the answer has changed now
if this is your answer that sounds a lot
better you know the only reason why it's
changed okay is that I'm trying to make
a bold point for him to latch off the
fact that he's on the [__] high road
he shows a high road of the whole
process okay that's your problem
when you are on the high road it is a
thin [__] it is a thin [__]
enrollment on a high road okay because
you have to be really tight with what
you do the things that you say and how
you act right I think he's doing fine
he's live every day for hours please
please please I'm talking to Ethan or
you uh don't interrupt me okay
um so Val you've taken the high road
okay you have to be really tight in how
he operates right so we say things like
oh well he does this and and I never do
this right well you are wrong and I just
told you you've been proven that what
okay so the designs you've stolen
that's called that's what they get FIFA
oh yeah piece of [__] garbage yes that
was not right when that happened okay it
hasn't happened a long time and we made
and we actually made efforts to prevent
it you have not you said your efforts to
prevent it with better thumbnails and
titles bro this is your example of
better thumbnails of time two weeks ago
same name same [__] thumbnail you the
guy you did the experiment sets changed
my thumbnail change the name be so that
my audience doesn't get confused and so
that you don't steal my views why are
you denying that it's so obvious
okay so like I said then like I said
um we answer the question what's the
question the question is how is it that
you can deny that you're stealing views
and intentionally misleading audience to
clicking your [__] video it
intentionally I that is not intentional
how is oh my God
go ahead let's say someone comes from
your stream they've watched you all day
they love you they're a big fan they
watched you react to let's say Mr
BEAST's new video okay yeah and then
they come to the home page and guess
what they see there Mr BEAST's new video
do you think they're there's are they
less likely or more likely to click his
video after they saw it on your Channel
um
I'm gonna answer the question dude
or less likely
okay okay no no no no no just answer one
or the other two choices
less got em yeah
did damn so so then that verse that
you're stealing things views
intentionally okay so so so the views
that and and the click rate are in that
particular instance do you think that
that will end up being a raw loss of the
Creator or not
sorry are we done talking about Daddy
Fresh yeah if we're done talking about
today I should be better because I don't
want it get out Thief before I [__]
Robin Hood this [__] before I start
explaining the wealth I'll be sure
you're coming to other people holy [__]
better come at you guys for staying some
designs Jesus Christ bro you're being
pretty silly but ours is defensible
yours is not or at least we've made it's
not defensible but anyway thank you know
what I mean I don't see this
conversation going guys guys it is
defensible thievery guys they did no I I
I I I'm stealing in the right way no I I
I retracted that as soon as I said it
right what you heard I said we've we've
corrected the air an understandable air
uh in my opinion one that you refuse to
remedy after time and time and time
again you provide me zero direct answers
and um and and frankly I think you know
you're wrong and I think you don't care
that you're wrong because it benefits
you greatly you make a lot of money you
don't want to change what you do and
here's another thing you're not gonna be
able to make uh 12 hours of content for
kick who paid you 100 million dollars if
you can't steal other people's content
because if you don't what the [__] you
gonna do all they sit there and gamble
nobody's gonna watch that [__] nobody's
gonna watch you this [__] already they
don't care about you even have arguments
clear you're not very good at that you
lost 12 viewers man
My Views are very good right now by the
way so I don't need like a therapist to
give us a hint on where when the Tantrum
ends when is the end Ethan it seems like
when you go on these tangents you just
you go on a rampage you just ramble and
ramble without making any concise point
or a question is that you're done with
that [__] do we talk like adults now or
not
um I think this conversation is kind of
been exhausted people would rather watch
me full screen can do the [__] worm
do watch the prime for a week do a week
of no reaction content and see how many
[__] views you get oh he's crying in
the corner
okay sure
I mean that's Compton man it's a rich
it's original content at least
yes do that bro
dude
this is the most funny videos [__]
four years [__] it's awesome dual week
of no react content
oh man oh even a day even a day
okay do one day without react content
I'm serious let's see um your wife's
merch cell
um sales on the on the first wave when
neither designs were stolen 90 let's do
the figures
you're just being you're just being
silly bro
let me silly prove me wrong because
clearly uh the burden of proof is is on
you now right because if you make an
argument then you have to prove it you
go ahead prove it you haven't even shown
I mean what yeah you're pretty silly bro
you're being ridiculous
well it seems like a I have to prove
everything and you have to prove nothing
here not at all what's not happening and
you've done nothing except prove some
different all right thank you buddy it
was a good chat
I think that we've done a good job
what you what you care about and uh how
you feel about taking people's videos I
think it was Illuminating I think we had
a really good conversation oh my God
it's over
yeah I mean I I don't think you have
anything else interesting to say so I
think we can really well I think your
audience thinks I have something
interesting to say it's just I promise
that you're right how long do you want
me to sit here and listen to you see
watch you crawl around on the ground
like a worm I might have a show to do
dude unlike you actually [__]
organize and put work into my show I
understand for you you're just burning
time you could sit here for 12 hours
that'd make your life easier you
wouldn't have to go steal videos but me
I plan this I have a show I have a
schedule this is stop being interesting
because you're just sitting there saying
silly [__] and doing the worm so with
that being said thank you for calling I
feel like it was very Illuminating and I
wish you the best and I hope you have a
great stream oh one more question
I wanted to ask him who is Mr chair
Mr chair
is here actually I'll show this [__] I
wanted to ask him that sorry no it's
okay it's okay it's it's that was not
going anywhere but here for the people
still watching
here's him talking about Mr chair I have
a concept in my chat um called Mr chair
if I'm gone and I'll watch a video and I
I leave uh Mr chair watch this video for
me and chat [__] loves Mr chairman
they like me that means that they like
the original video
which the views of which you're stealing
but he's he's saying yeah I just walk
away in my chair my chair does the work
for me
it can't be understated that the chair
adds value
the chair
he said the chair the empty chair adds
value how can I have a conversation with
this guy the truth is that
he wants to be radically honest about
what he's doing he wants to say I don't
care about this I'm doing it I don't
care he wants to make a million
he wants to make a million uh
exceptions oh if they come to me I'll
pay them putting the the [__] onus on
the victim to come to him the biggest
content creator in the world where
there's a huge power Dynamic the one guy
I did talk to Vince says he doesn't want
the Heat and of course why would he
right I mean he's clearly not very
stable to begin with him he hasn't slept
in a [__] day and so uh you know
sending him a complaint could easily
backfire on somebody
and um
he wants to be radically honest about it
but when he when it comes time to
explain
what he's doing is wrong he won't own it
he's radically honest up to a point
where you say why are you naming it the
same title and the same thumbnail as
their video because I wanted to he he
can't he can't go there because he knows
he's wrong
does this mean
sorry but it's true
and I mean the diver the reason I was
asking about
another point I didn't get to finish was
why does it matter if I'm a hypocrite
why does that matter we're having a
conversation a philosophical
conversation about fair use about using
people's content I am trying to stay on
the topic and have a productive useful
philosophical question if he's like
you're a hypocrite how does that and by
the way I addressed everything he said
okay I just wanted to have a feel I just
wanted to understand where he was coming
from if I'm a hypocrite how does that
enhance or change
the debate we're having he's literally
literally just deflecting that's all he
was doing the whole time
so it was about as productive as I
thought it would be but uh
what do you guys think
it's funny I mean I had to hang up on
him this was not
like I said he's got a 12 hours to burn
yeah yeah I don't know we bought we
brought like a victim like a good
example of him stealing it from an actor
[__]
like it's his first response is it's a
paid actor that's awesome and then his
second response is oh well he doesn't
matter he's just one person yeah he's so
content brand
and then he goes well where's all your
victims and I says I don't know
it's possible I've done it yeah but like
well you've been trying to link to me
every week right yeah I mean people
don't come to me every week and say
please stop doing this or Twitter drama
or people constantly telling him hey
this isn't cool any dozen dozen dozen
does it
he also like laid out exactly what he
could do to remedy the situation and
then like clearly didn't mean any of it
but like he said I'm gonna make an
effort to like make my thumbnails
different blah blah and then like the
argument slipped on its head because he
wouldn't ground himself enough actually
he didn't say that he says improve his
thumbnails oh it improved which is from
two weeks ago literally carbon copy yeah
they're all with the only there's only
one explanation for that literature
siphon views period dude yeah period
all he has to do is tell his editors to
make it look different like that's all
he has to do but they don't want to
right because they're lazy and they
don't want to change and it's easy and
he likes things that are easy and he
won't admit that he's against putting
work into things
dude [__] paid actor
that's crazy how much did you pay that
guy you know who uh out of curiosity
dude I swear to God there was a I I've
had a list of a few people that I
sourced from his recent reactions and of
the list there was one person that
followed me this guy Vince by the way I
did want to say about Vince
that he is a super talented Vince
vintage is a super talented creator
that you all should please uh go check
out and subscribe watch one of his
videos
um
here I'll pull it up but his videos are
really great and I mean it's straight
from his mouth you know what I mean I
don't know what I don't know what else
to say about it
this is a video he reacted to and then
this is another video he reacted to both
with the identical thumbnail
and the identical
title
and it's okay like I know he's a piece
of [__] he doesn't care and that's fine
but he can't admit it to only to a point
right and then it's you're a hypocrite
so it doesn't matter nothing matters
because you're a hypocrite how does me
being a hypocrite matter at all to this
conversation I don't understand really
don't
I'll tell you who's the paid actor
[__] xqc who's coming here acting
pretending like to care about people at
all and he's getting paid 100 million
dollars from kick but
that's it I don't know what's to say it
yeah I got it the dude sucks
he sucks
what more can you say man doesn't care
I don't know that was pretty cool when
it crawled like a worm I hope he does
more of that that was good content that
was actually the most he probably gained
16 viewers when he did that definitely
hope he takes up your challenge to do it
for a week but I would love for him to
do a week without react content
or how about this you can only react to
stuff you get Express Express written
permission for
I mean obviously the guy has no
standards he made fun of my Tourette's
he called Ila a [__] like she he said
she has 90 stolen designs which is like
silly obviously what was the uh
the bald thing I don't know I was weird
I said bro I have I am the king of the
hairline
are you I I guess he's trying to make a
joke I don't know yeah he's trying to
like prove that oh what if I say
something that's false or untrue oh yeah
he is actually complimenting it's just
right it doesn't make sense because it
doesn't make any sense because it's it's
you can literally disprove that which I
did to most of the [__] he said
you know
I don't know what to say
I think I said it all
oh you know what I know there was two
things he wanted me to say he wanted to
say to me because the guy's such a [__]
he talked about all this [__] on stream
how what a dumbass uh he says one he's
never gambled on kick
which I apologize for if that's true I'm
sorry for speaking out of turn for that
I would like to ask him are you ever
gonna gamble on Kik that's a question
but as far as I know he hasn't yet and
so I apologize for speaking out of turn
kick and then the other one was that he
got permission for a specific video I
mentioned on leftovers so I apologize
for that as well even though I did prove
uh that you did not ask for permission
from Vince which was just one sample of
a
of hundreds frankly
so there it is
I think he has actual opinions but then
he looks over like he wants to have an
argument like an actual good good faith
argument then he looks over to his chat
and he sees the chat like memeing around
the juicer and he just cannot resist to
trolling a little bit I don't think he
has arguments I I think he's probably
deep inside the beginning
seemed like it would maybe lead to
something predictive when I brought out
the hard-hitting points yeah like the
thumbnail comparison like this
testimonial from Vince he cannot answer
it he cannot be honest with me because
the the paid actor thing that was his
idea that was his shot spamming I mean
what am I I don't know no that's my
choice and he saw so his chat is like oh
that's funny that's a clip that's
content I'm in uh it's really Dumber
that period because I brought up a
really good point and instead of
actually addressing it
and trying to dispel this this myth
apparently according to him that he's
not a Content Thief he has the
opportunity to address that and he says
paid actor
this man called me bald oh come on guys
I don't approve of that
ah I will warn him though that that
hairline's about to get a lot thinner
and mine's about to keep going down to
my [__] eyebrows
I don't know I I hope I hope I did okay
in truth I knew it was going to be I was
considering canceling it because the
fair use some is something that I do
care about and I knew it was going to be
a mess and it was going to be
potentially just not productive But
ultimately I decided to go through with
it
and I hope that there was something
valuable in it I don't know if there was
oh [__] yeah it made him look really
[__] dumb uh I hope so that's a big
dub when does the Tantrum end Ethan and
then here's a picture of him crawling on
the floor can I say something yes please
Ela I I thought you did good by the way
thank you I'm sorry about that [__]
he was saying to you what a dick I
totally wasn't even planning on being
here it all just happened and then he
was asking about Teddy fresh and I was
like well why don't you ask me like why
do they always have to bring that up
when they talk to you
right well you were here no you were and
then he goes oh ela's here it's like
well yeah you're calling her out I
didn't I don't work on Teddy fresh like
that and the only reason I brought up
him wearing the Gucci shirt it's just
because like
it's like all the money goes to you you
know you're using all this content
people are spending hours on thousand
percent somebody spent time making that
thumbnail and thinking about the title
you know all this stuff people are
working on and you give no credit no
nothing 100 and it's not up to him to
make that decision to say I'm gonna
steal your content and if you have a
problem with it you can come to me
because truly as Vince said to me I'm
not going to exercise my dmca because I
don't want the heat that's going to come
down on me the drama
think about it do you know how many
times people have gotten to like mad
[__] for dmca on YouTube it's been like
huge internet scandals yep
that's not an absurd thing you have to
acknowledge the power Dynamic there dude
you just don't care
you know it's crazy to say he's
basically saying like oh yeah I commit
crimes and then if anyone complains I'll
pay them handsomely
right like it's not your it's not yours
to make that decision right right so
like sure maybe a lot of people will be
fine if they get paid off but it's still
a big deal right it's not his how about
you contact them get permission and then
pay them how about that yeah you pay
them before you steal their content
you're such a good guy because his
YouTube views are high well also a lot
yeah and it's a low quality like easy
it's so easy just copy paste boom up
you're making a lot of money on that
YouTube channel a lot yeah I'd say may I
don't know a hundred thousand a month
maybe probably so maybe more I don't
know but you can see the the amount they
do which wouldn't be he's already
oh he's he's posted uh him reacting to
me watching me Canyon my friend who I
literally by the way go to Instagram I'm
pretty sure I even have a conversation
with him and the DM's asking for his
permission to watch it on stream which
I'll actually I guess it could be useful
to pull up let's see
let me see what is wrong with you I
don't think it matters because we're
friends and I know that he's cool with
it and and I know that twitch streamers
also experience that that's a different
issue
let's see
talked a bit
okay
just going up we're friends so we talk a
bit you know what I mean
the part where he got on the ground
crawled around
dub that's a dub well here check this
out I mean I think just because that's
just that's good content would you still
love me if I was a worm he asks
I don't know cry cry
maybe try being a worm for a day see
what happens maybe it's good for you I
don't know
you know what I mean [__]
it's pretty good
uh I didn't realize we talked this much
Jesus
um
are you looking up that DM I'm just
looking through my dams with me Canyon
I'll read some of these I think there's
a point that could have been made about
Ethan saying that he hasn't had any
creators reach out to him but then had
Vince as proof
what
um he was talking about xqc I think
there was a point that could have been
made about Ethan saying that he hasn't
had any creators reached out to him but
then had Vince as proof I literally I'm
not sure I don't know what that means
I'm not sure I follow the logic of that
I mean one thing I will say to be fair
to xqc here I'm going to make a point
for him that he could never come up with
his on his own go ahead you said that
nobody nobody's ever complained to you
about stealing their videos you could
say that that is the same power dynamic
as with xqc yes they don't want the
smoke from the H3 Nation yes my point
only point is that I'm saying I've
likely not done good reactions I don't
know though I don't have any I don't
have any proof right I don't the
difference is you you acknowledge if I
did that I was wrong because he doesn't
want to he has proof people literally
calling him out for this every week
right and he does publicly get people to
call him out but yeah but like like
definitely that could be a power Dynamic
play but that wasn't the point I was
making is I don't have any evidence to
show you
that this is something that happens you
know what I mean
uh
I see right people are clearing because
because Vince didn't reach out either
right so similar to what I was just
saying yes
um well he explicitly said he didn't
want to deal with xqc because it was
right there's definitely more yeah if
you don't want to like get the hate also
it's a twitch Community twitch
communities versus youth communities I'd
argue are more active because twitch is
so interactive it's like the War Room
yeah it's a twitch twitch quizzes are
super powerful oh yeah dude it's
definitely
big Power
our difference so I don't know I mean
were you saying something did I cut you
off you made your point okay good
how long was that you didn't cut me off
is that a long one
an hour somebody said get off get Hunter
on the potty are you talking about
Hunter Biden because that'd be sick dude
let's see that car interview
right there
smoking crack in a brand new turbo
back together yeah
I'm saying one crack pipe one love you
bring out the fun one Porsche oh oh oh I
see Hunter is uh I see that's me that's
me oh that's me Canon I I
I'm still putting forward the hunter
Biden idea though bro he [__] but don't
you guys think that this is almost like
undeniable why he would do the title and
thumbnail yeah he literally the fact
that it is slightly changed is uh
interesting unless I mean maybe the
maybe the original thumbnail changed he
just zoomed in a little bit so that I
think he thought it would be better the
text on different lines there's a lot of
transformation because they got to fit
the text with his face in there right
right but if you go through his channel
they're all literally all yeah I mean
yeah clearly does it and I don't know
there it is I don't know what to say I
don't know yeah I'm not perfect and when
I have done it it's also wrong you know
what I mean I don't know what to say
here he is reacting hard
yeah buddy get it
get that [__] funny and relatable tick
tocks yo both at the same time
how's that oh yeah yeah
look at this like dude this actually it
does what does IQ actually measure whoa
dude
I actually watched that video the other
day
I watched the original also I did get
him force him to admit basically that
what he's doing is wrong by saying
if somebody from your stream watches the
new Mr Beast video
the whole thing with you sitting there
with Mr chair
then they come to the YouTube homepage
Mr peace Mr Beast video is on the home
page are they more or less likely to
kick that video the the real answer is
because I didn't want to get too extreme
because I wanted to force him to answer
the real answer is almost nobody's
probably going to click it to re-watch
it
but I don't think he'd be willing to
even admit that
sure
sure Hunter Biden shown in lap new
laptop photo driving 172 in a brand new
to Las Vegas orgy Turbo S Porsche wait
how did they know he was going to a Las
Vegas orgy
oh my God invite on the dash
it's a mess of a human 174
bro that's pretty easy to do that in the
car though to be honest that's not that
car I'm not saying it's not easy it's
psychotic to drive that fast
if you crash he's got to get to the orgy
he's gonna wait for me you guys miss the
buffet dude don't start without me uh
here's uh this is just the one we
randomly pick does IQ actually what does
IQ actually measure whoa what does IQ
actually measure that one was not a
juicer though no his audience is not
interested in not thinking about IQ type
I think it's just kidding yeah just
kidding yeah
and then the Hassan thing it's like dude
what are you talking about I mean she
grilled him he react to that video so I
that one he doesn't really have an
excuse I mean that that you guys had a
heated argument about it and he watched
it that's what I'm saying is he reacted
it to it so he wasn't just told about it
he's just he's just not honest he's just
lying yeah you know you know what can
you do literally lying yeah and also I
yeah so it's like yeah I grilled Hassan
hard bro and you watched the video dummy
uh there it is there it is well
hopefully he's doing the worm and
you know eating dirt like I was against
this conversation taking place but as
soon as he as soon as his belly hit the
floor and he started crawling around
like that I was like you know what
this is YouTube magic baby yeah we got
him on the ground folks when are you
gonna stop having a tantrum right to the
floor yeah doing the worm baby so I
don't know that's it I guess that's all
I have to say that's it anything else
anyone wants to add
anything good on the subreddit no uh the
twitch Reddit is lacking what happened
and they're not your favor did twitch
read it yeah like there's a torch Reddit
yeah oh that's the twitch yeah it's
pretty much I mean it's kind of The
Unofficial
those guys are wild man I'm scared of
them they're on your side they are yeah
thank you guys thank you I love live
stream fails big respect for the
community always love what you guys do
[Applause]
they're they're really ruthless now
they're they're scared me again oh man
even a day even a day
[Applause]
[Music]
yes we got him hold on oh even a day
even a day
okay so one day without reacting okay
good well that was and I thought it was
so funny how he comes with like the bad
faith Playbook with the teddy fresh well
we knew that and then he's uploading
he's up dude he actually uploaded okay
this I need to talk about
because he was unwilling to understand
how dumb it was this man actually
uploaded
a clip of me
that's super edited
as proof that I don't react hard enough
wait this is mine
this video is crazy and he goes yeah
what's the problem 1.2 million views in
six hours okay King he's like what's the
problem not only did he cut out the
whole beginning which is important I
hate to tell him
finally over caught one Logan Paul
apologized coffeezilla your slime is he
is a lopsided journalist with an agenda
more like an internet criminal oops
wrong video that was the first response
he actually apologize too he just zoomed
in look at this all right I mean
it's how you know what I mean like I
don't know
they cut out they literally cut out
commentary I'm pretty sure which does
not really help his argument I have to
say
and again what does it even matter
because I admit I have done it okay
I admit but I want to have a
conversation about the act itself if
I've done it I don't think matters and
I'm willing to say I did you're not
it was really clear I mean I I would
Hazard to guess I mean maybe he even
said this but you know
did he say it it's hard to tell
sometimes I apologize I know he's got an
accent but the uh
the
video that you showed of him
was edited
and the video that he has is edited I'm
the difference is there's no Cuts in his
well and the difference is that those
videos are demonstrating different
things he you edited a video of all of
his commentary he edited a video taking
out your commentary well that's
literally right good faith versus bad
faith argument exactly yeah right he's
like the the goal of those two edits
were very different yes you might say
that yes I was going to say clearly
doesn't understand what fair use is
though like the whole thing was painful
to watch yeah he just doesn't care
though because like I I when preparing
for this I said I'm gonna not even talk
about fair use I don't care about the
law because he doesn't care about it so
whatever I say he'll just say I don't
care so I plan to just skip that whole
part because it wasn't going to be
valuable at all
so I said okay let's talk about the
philosophical
aspect of it
we should we should have like a hater
Bingo where
he brought up you being fat
did it fresh old divorce divorce divorce
all of them it's so funny every single
time yeah it's pretty great
fantastic we have a winner xqc what did
you win
[Music]
well I tell you what you definitely
owned Vince 10x whatever Revenue you got
on both those videos and I'll make sure
he reaches out for that
probably won't just because he doesn't
want [__]
paid actor uh my good friend paid actor
Vince vintage
here's the conversation with him by the
way in case anybody was wondering
literally reached out last night
literally last night at 8 20.
hey bro can I ask you a cue I'm curious
if xqc ever contacted you to ask for
permission to react your vids also I'm
curious how you felt about it thank you
dude that and then he responded
there you go there you go guys hey
doctor
wait careful for notifications oh boy
we believe you we believe you
it's pretty it's pretty out of focus but
we get the idea yeah and there's this
big statement wow nice all right
probably should have kept that yeah and
the finger on the button
uh
also some people pointed out his like
misogyny showing and the way that he was
talking to me oh yeah I felt a little
bit stop talking I'm not talking to you
I'm talking to you don't cut me up yes I
wondered when he said that would he have
said that to me I don't know
people are saying Vince was in the chat
during the debate I'll be honest I was
intentionally not looking at the chat
paid actor um Vince Vince yeah he was in
the chat I saw him oh really he was
saying this is so crazy too much paid
actor dude
you know what he's the xqc is going to
treat him like uh
Vince is a great guy you know it's not a
good analogy but you know how like the Q
Anon people start turning on on I was
about to say Ray Epps he's gonna be the
ray Epps you're a [__] paid actor
it's great
all right
dude I think we should move on we've
we've thought about this man enough
today
there it is
that's all I have to say about that
so I guess we'll address the fousey
thing now
that that's done
uh the frying pan into the fire I mean
it basically went as as well as I
thought it would my guy he's hard to pin
down because he just would never answer
anything and that was my fear I mean
what she which exposes him in a way but
we've seen the other arguments I don't
even remember what it's about which just
goes to show how high level of the
discourse was but when him and Hassan
were hardcore beefing like a year ago
and they they got on a call and they
were like screaming at each other for
hours that's what he wanted to do with
me
well yeah I mean because that's for him
that's great content exactly right he
said oh you're leaving it's like yeah
bro but yeah based off of remembering
how those pastimes would go I uh
it went about
about as well as I think any of us could
have been hopefully I exposed that at
least in some parts he is wrong
dishonest
bad faith
and uh
that's pretty much it really my guy
my guy my guy oh that's [__] tip
big tip got me probably should have kept
that to yourself my guy we have uh we
have fresh clips
wait what is this from
this is Hassan reacting to it oh from
what just happened yeah oh good I love
these dude and by the way Hassan editors
do not [__] put this whole thing up I
do not give you permission to do that so
rip this whole [__] thing during the
show and use the same title and
thumbnail hell no I do not give you
permission his his editors would not do
that no well you're talking about like
right the the road the Rogue agents yeah
the Rogue editor yeah right I think it's
called like hassanabi Capital One and
Two
yeah cracker don't [__] do it those
ones he showed us were crazy where all
the old videos were like Vietnamese
cartoon yes and then it just turned into
a Hassan Channel dude do you know that
person's like Rich As [__] though in
Vietnam yep make it like crazy
I listen I appreciate the hustle don't
watch those videos please people are
straight up just stealing content
anyway what did Hassan think s these
arguments like uh regardless of the
words that he uses that he's learned
from other people that he's like trying
to deploy in a really wrong manner
because it doesn't work in the situation
it's always no you it boils down to oh
what about you dude that was the point I
was trying to make about calling me a
hypocrite it's like okay you can say no
you all day long let's have actually
talk about it we're sucking his balls
out well that's right Mr chair reacts
and uh I can't believe you've actually
even said this so it's honest you don't
you don't even know what you're talking
about last week I chewed him out for an
hour to the point where I had to
apologize because people were mad at me
people wait did this turn to me now yeah
it is my problem did this [__] dumb
duh of course he was gonna bring you up
to Becker three IQ Schnauzer snake rat
say I'm chair reacts you [__] sucking
[__] [__] you chair guy you're
the chair guy yeah Mr chair
that was the one thing I wanted to ask
him who is Mr chair
who's Mr chair sorry Nancy's fine you
had the directive
but um
yeah I challenge you to find a video on
YouTube of Hassan's not properly editing
and cutting it and doing transformative
His official channels edits are great
super clean completely above board
God I would have loved to get his
response to that though who's Mr chair
you say
but who who's Mr chair and then you go
listen the point I'm trying to make is
this no who is Mr chair
okay when I leave for like 10 minutes
people like when I'm not there and they
just think the chair is awesome and we
just watch the video and let it play
great all right let's talk about fousey
I need to wind down a little bit my guy
my guy
my guy my guy yeah you probably
uh maybe I'll do I'll do something else
first so I I can wind down a little bit
we can talk about the kai sinat the I
mean it was all mad you talk about
Baldur's Gate that's all I want to talk
about
Baldur's Gate Baldur's Gate three came
out
sure did sixty dollars right
um was it 17. games are like 70 nowadays
are they not I don't even remember
because I think it was 60. [__] Kings
Kings over there Larry and stuff what's
interesting about this game is that they
set up front there's no oh it was 70.
okay
there was no micro transactions there is
no
extra cells this is the full game this
is what it is and the game that they
delivered was finished it was great it's
amazing and this here's what happens
when you do that in contrast to all the
scummy [__] who are making games
today
um looking at you blizzard Activision
[__]
uh
you're so 800 000 people were playing it
concurrently that's insane want a top
record for Steam yeah I mean you know it
didn't surpass the Counter-Strike which
is the perennial like number one on
there or whatever but generally you know
single player
story games like this don't get as high
as things you know competitive
multiplayer games so the fact that it
was even close to that is pretty wild
is that it you want to say anything else
oh you wanted to talk I thought you
wanted to talk about
I was I just I that was it I don't know
it's fun Try It Out Try It Out yeah
okay
on uh on Steam what so did you play it
did you try it yeah I played it a bit
the problem is like when I hit story
games
the dialogue isn't corny and painful to
get through it's good I think it's
really and the voice acting is good it
feels good but the problem is when I'm
down there playing I'm usually with Elam
or watching vanderplump or something and
so I can't play this game on mute like I
usually play so I haven't got as much
time to play it as I would like to but I
have spent about like two or three hours
on it so I'm not a gamer by any means
but you play majority of video games
with no volume
basically almost all of them yeah
exclusively plays with no sound can I
can I ask why is it because you have
you're something else you're doing while
you're playing hey it's always watching
I find that the the
consuming something or living in the
outside world where I'm with Ila or I'm
watching something or I'm listening to
music is gonna it adds a lot more than
this video game sound does got it for me
I mean listen you play Diablo 3 you
don't you don't need that [__] audio
man that's like literally all it sounds
like it's [__] annoying it's crazy to
listen to that sound for that
crazy if you don't mute it anyway uh
that's that all right let's talk about
Kai sanat
so it was yesterday
was it yesterday no Monday Friday what
no wait what is today today Monday my
dude whoa time warped yesterday it was
uh last Friday yesterday
um last Friday
sorry Mitch mcconn I just Mitch
mcconnelled hard
this is my favorite new man
[Music]
three
wait I need to pull that up dude Mitch
McConnell was doing a speech amongst his
own constituents yeah and they started
yelling at him
drowning him out telling him retire
let me grab it for you
I bet he couldn't even hear him huh
brutal did cat hasanabi Capital already
upload it
definitely let me see no he didn't yet
or not that one he has another one let's
see
hassanabe Capital two he has
you know
I don't see it yet thank you for not
doing that hopefully you don't yeah he
didn't do it shout out to my Indonesian
friend or whoever you are Wherever You
Are
all right so the kai sanat thing there's
a ton of footage that came out you know
we watched it live unfolding but in the
aftermath there was so much
craziness
you're running so Ethan leaves the
debate after he couldn't beat xqc this
is awesome I want to watch this how long
do you want me to sit here and listen to
you see watch you crawl around on the
ground like a worm I might have a show
to do dude unlike you I actually [__]
organize and put work into my show I
understand for you you're just burning
time you can sit here for 12 hours
that'd make your life easier you
wouldn't have to go steal videos but me
I plan this I have a show I have a
schedule this stop being interesting
because you're just sitting there saying
silly [__] and doing the work so with
that being said thank you how is this me
losing I feel like I just roasted him
pretty good yeah absolutely dude he's
posting his elves yeah it's very
generous Illuminating and I wish you the
best and I hope you have a great day you
look so defeated
then what
they posted that they posted posting
their house that's brutal bro dude what
why did you post that
W okay x-u-c train this is his own fans
xqc trying to debate people it's like
Stephen Hawking trying to shoot a
three-pointer
Jesus
yikes
Ethan is completely wrong according to
at yeggs underscore one with the
Garfield Emoji xqc had all the arguments
decided to use none of them that's a
shame
apparently he wins but only if we use
our imagination and he used the argument
if only uh that commenter could have
gotten on the call
own you dude
yeah here's the Mitch McConnell clip
it's so [__] good you know I hate it
look at this old [__] he doesn't even
know they're chanting you oh yeah he
tried calling me old too by the way xqc
he's like old I was like okay classic
he's just like oh they love old man love
for me yeah it's harder it's hard to be
old on YouTube it's a testament
right old man somebody's pretty old out
here in these streets testify
he's just reading he doesn't know
that's what I'm saying
sounds like a refrigerator
dude the [__] Bell is so good every
time
look at this dude in the back look at
his face
[Music]
things that are sharing that they're
chanting we love it we love Mitch
keep going keep going
yeah everything's fine in this country
uh we're doing great
step to Mitch McConnell age 81 just had
a stroke on television
oh [__] they got us [__] they got us
dude GG okay so I gotta take this down
I'm just not cool with this this is this
is what xqc actually does Ethan debating
xqc on copyright hasanabe reacts and
then what's [__] up is they're using
it in Hassan's name
he's not associated with these people
what a transmission huge huge yeah I
don't I don't even know how to do a dmca
which is kind of crazy I've I don't
think I've ever done I've done a few
through my network but I don't not with
the network now and I literally have no
idea how to do it
try it let's do it on the show I want to
dmca this for real it's not cool what
they're doing
straight up what xqc is doing which is
why Dan
and they're doing it in Hassan's name
okay
wouldn't it be fair use if Hassan's but
it's okay A song can upload this to his
channel
so yeah I don't think they're authorized
this would be considered a theft of
I guess if you want to make that
argument Hassan's content right Hassan
would have to
I don't know I think I'd be in my right
to do it saying he doesn't have the
proper license
I think I'm in my right to remove it
and I would do want to
because those videos always end up with
like hundreds of thousands of views
anyway let's see some Kai sanat footage
so he actually we were debating if he
got a permit on Friday and we're like he
had to he had to he didn't I was uh yeah
I was one of the main people saying that
I was just like there's just no way
because
um you know I'm not uh
I'm not somebody that follows his
content really closely or anything but I
you know he's huge and a lot of the
content of his that I have seen seems
well organized and produced yeah and so
it just to me seemed out of the question
that his handlers or or whoever his team
would
do something like that without getting
the proper
permits and everything I just I I was
pretty confident in feeling that way and
turns out nope that's not true at all I
mean totally wrong it's so hard to
believe people are saying Hassan saying
on a stream to strike the video
could somebody look up how to do that I
legit don't know
um
oh Hassan Capital uploaded it too guess
what guys I'm coming for all you [__]
all you xqc wannabes what's even worse
they're just wholesale stealing Hassan's
content and my content
and literally stealing our views too
I find it hard to believe that Kai sanat
did not have one person in his life to
say this is not a good idea
that you need a permit to do this find
that interesting
and shocking frankly but here's NBC News
this is how you know he's really [__]
story on it
tonight charges filed against a social
media star for allegedly sparking a
massive riot in Manhattan's Union Square
leading to 65 arrests and multiple
injuries
oh that's the kid who's whose face they
put through the window
by the way so there's a video of them
smashing that kid's face through the
window I watched it so many times to try
to figure out what's going on the kid
they smashed through the window did
nothing he was just standing bystander
he did nothing yep there was one dude
who smashed the window and he ran off
and the police came took the dude in the
red hoodie that you just saw and slammed
his head through glass windshield bro
all right people this is actual this is
actual face
pick them cones they threw chairs police
charge influencer Kai Sonata with
inciting a riot an unlawful assembly he
avoided the spotlight while being
released from custody everybody for
themselves because there's a war out
there man and now for the first time
we're seeing how the event unfolded
can't twitch streamers like get their
[__] together like how many times are we
gonna do this you're number one man you
got the world in the palm of your hand
well you got to do this kind of dumb
[__] it looks so bad for tonight
in a live stream of his arrival in Union
Square
where it was police that had to save him
from them he created
is that human right away like a baby
yeah is that humiliating to be like man
like that a little bit
very mess he created you have to pull up
two days before the incident he posted
online that he was going to be holding a
giveaway
random questions bro if you get it right
it's crazy he thought he was actually
there was he was actually gonna like
talk to these people and have like a
civil exchange with them
I feel like his audience is bigger than
ours
I feel like if I did this I know it
would be chaos it would be crazy yeah
for sure and there would be a lot less
people showing up for me
yeah but I mean you've had experience
with that kind of stuff and um I
remember you wasn't it in Sweden that
you like did one of these like fan
meetups and it was like I'm a madhouse
well so we we planned it luckily we we
rented out a venue actually pay uh the
payday guys did they're so oh yeah there
you go they rented out a venue even got
security guards but it was way crazier
than we expected see and that's good
they they knew where were you love how
was the [__] were you it was during I
think uh it was like during finals dude
I think you timed it up with finals I
remember wanting to go I'm kidding yeah
that would have been crazy
full circle wow yeah really nice
everyone there in Sweden
anyway
the promise of gaming consoles gear and
100 gift cards all MTA trains
not in school yet so quick so create
your schedules it's not posting this do
you say don't go to school come to this
anyway yeah you guys get the picture but
so he's actually been charged and
apparently from what I read he's facing
potentially
and
take this with a grain of salt but up to
five years yeah it'll get they'll get
played down but the thing is I'm pretty
sure that the NYPD is going to want to
make an example of him
and frankly
I don't think they're wrong for doing
that it was crazy what he did
yeah I don't know
I don't know you can't do that no I
agree and he needs to learn a hard
lesson about I don't know I think
slamming him with a shitload of fines
and stuff is enough I I don't I don't
shitload of fines well it depends how
much you know what I mean ten thousand
is not enough how old is this guy I mean
how old is kaisanet let me look five
thousand dollars but people I don't know
what to do because these switch
streamers they don't stop doing this
dumb [__]
I mean if he were to do something like
this again
uh you know obviously but I don't know
you're like 21. this whole blow up
happened over covid and like I I mean
maybe maybe I'm wrong maybe I don't have
enough information if this was the first
time that he tried to do something like
this and just massively underestimated
his own reach oh somebody said he knows
school is out he's not encouraging
people to skip school okay that's good
right right summer yeah
I feel bad for him his team should have
advised him better I don't think he was
that's the thing I feel like the people
around him should like he's he's the
talent he's a 21 year old kid and like
you know
I see that he has an agency and stuff
I'm seeing he's a manager
yeah where the [__] were they that's a
good point I think now if if they all
told him don't do this and he did it
anyways that's a different story
obviously but I don't know I just kind
of feel like that's a good point yeah I
think you're right as a young kid he's
just out there he doesn't know what's
going on but it's super [__] Rich
right from his success so like I mean
yeah he's probably a millionaire by now
he should get slammed with a bunch of
fees that's gonna suck but he can afford
it and you know apparently he said
somebody was not a lesson he said clog
up MTA
okay but yeah somebody failed him I
don't know
I don't know
the Riverboat stuff I can't show it it's
too violent but boy that clip was
awesome
the Riverboat yeah yeah somebody there
was like a video
Riverboat brawl and
Alabama where was it
uh Alabama
or Arkansas one of the two I think it
was Alabama you guys should go watch it
I can't show it yeah yeah it was Alabama
so there's a boat of these white trash
[__] they're at this dock
and there's a worker there he told them
before you cannot park your boat there
because there's a ferry coming in that
that's a lot of that spot
so the ferry comes they left the boat
and they left it there in the ferry
can't park
so he starts moving the boat he starts
untying it and pushing it away and then
all these white trash [__] come
and jump him
they just straight up started bad start
jumping him
and then like it was just so beautiful
all these people started like coming to
his defense a dude jumped off the ferry
and swam to the dock
to join The Fray people were people were
falling in the water I guess we really
can't watch it [__] it's but I you
should watch it it is Iconic no seek it
out it's a fantastic and but these guys
got their ass beat and they also got
arrested although some of the other
people defend him got arrested and I
hope that I hope that they don't get
charged because they were so in the
right these guys were so in the wrong
man so gross what they did they're but
people were falling in the water there
was hair pulling there was someone with
a chair he came out with a chair and
slamming people over the head WWE [__]
dude I mean the chair came out dude it
was crazy so apparently you've seen the
picture of the Crocs I think that's from
the fight
hold on let me post this oh let me show
this I just posted it on Twitter
did this is how gnarly
this brawl got you guys are gonna
[__] love this here
this check it
you see those Crocs
you ever seen anything like that in your
life oh
dude
so awesome
that is a powerful photograph right
there it's one of the all-time great
internet videos and it was record there
were so many people there was recorded
from the fairy it recorded from the dock
there's all these angles uh it's
fantastic
what's this can I watch this one I need
to see this man
really damn all right
bro how did you do that wow you're right
he just has his hand on the bottom of
his back oh man it was oh my God that is
fantastic amazing
I'm trying I I'm genuinely trying to
think like running panics running no
sports mode oh no sports mode he just
went wow
input the lever where it was supposed to
be
are you sure is is the same like
incident I or is this it is I think it
is because it looks like a different
dock I don't know oh yeah you're right
this isn't the same spot yeah this is
different just the same look at him oh
even get the same walk but we do get the
same walk okay this is a difference yeah
I think this is a different thing this
is [__] in front of this boy you out
there brother okay Croc's about to
release those for real
ankle warmers vitamins is about to
release those for ten thousand dollars
that's so funny they're cheering for him
he's a superstar I mean have you ever
seen anyone do that not a pair of Crocs
oh no
[Applause]
all right let's talk about fousey I
guess at this point oh there's a lot of
Clips let's see if someone still stole a
truck
I can't show that one of the police
smashing the head through I don't think
yeah do we have the one uh
love made it an edit where it ends
literally the frame before his head goes
through the window so you can maybe show
that without because you don't actually
see the
gives you an idea without seeing it
okay I think that's fair no yeah so if
you Analyze This I watched this so many
times
so there are people being you know
breaking [__] so there's a dude who's
slamming the window there now this is
the guy who gets body slammed right in
the road so so
this dude's smashing [__] he runs the
guy in the red is just like what's going
on didn't do anything boom dude right
through the glass
and then there's a video of him or a
picture of him crying with blood on his
face in custody yeah uh
get [__] up
NYPD baby
here's a comment I guess of Kai saying
he knew it was going to be a [__] show
before it went down let's see
yeah 500 people could fit right there
they said more
NYPD gonna be on date
nyp is going to pull up oh [__] it bro
all right we go all outside I'm telling
you bro this is gonna be a [__] movie
dude straight up lifetime's about to
make a movie about this
yeah it's not great look pretty wild not
a great look to be that like I don't
know I mean I know he's 21 but that's
really that's really irresponsible I'm
21. also he's done meetups he knows how
intense his fans are or how many of them
there are right I mean well that's what
I was saying is I I don't actually know
that because I've seen him do meetups
with massive crowds I'm pretty sure okay
I mean fair enough I don't know
this one was really sad people were
beating up or hit a street venue and
started like stealing his chips it's
like why why did you do that
some people are trying to help him and
then other people are just like let's
get some Doritos
[Music]
listen it comes from poverty at the end
of the day so
people don't steal [__] unless they
remember this was forever ago when I was
in high school
uh
way back in the day in the olden days
for all you youngins uh there was a
little thing called the Iraq war that
was about to happen and our school did a
a walk-out protest in a lot of it's
really doing a similar kind of thing
what and a group of about I think it was
like 30 maybe 40 people
the walkout meant let's go across the
street to a gas station and ransack it
that is so [__] crazy and that's the
thing is like you get you get a bunch of
hormonal [__] Rowdy ass kids together
that is uh wow that's great [__] pops
off I mean I don't know like you have to
plan for that you have to expect that
listen I'm not I'm I'm not super butt
hurt about people stealing the Mountain
Dew in a bag of Doritos it looks like
someone hit him that's [__] oh yeah
for sure looks like he got her I don't
like that you know
um dancing on a car
take a look at this one
this I mean
I guess people don't really realize that
like you're on video I don't know
because like the police are gonna rest
this guy for sure I mean literally every
single one of them is
everyone in the crowd has the phone out
every single person it's like that guy's
got a straight DSLR dude yeah what
Olivia they all think that they're still
in chat it feels like oh like they're
all Anonymous yeah
[Applause]
I'm never telling my chat to go touch
grass ever again right I saw that very
true this is what happens when you touch
grass trust me you're just way happier
watch these kids inside watching
watching twitch but yeah I mean kids
listen you're gonna get arrested if
you're doing this [__] like for sure
but that's what it is
shout out Kai
here's another one of people stomping a
car windshield
let's see
my guy
hopefully gonna get arrested
I don't know whose car is that like
[Applause]
is that even somebody's car that you
want to break
[Music]
I couldn't tell if anybody was in there
or not
probably should have kept that to
yourself they were blocking active
streets I don't know if someone was in
there that's a good question probably
wait there's nothing so like haunting
about all of the arms up in the air with
the phone it's just that
I don't know it's dude it's world star
it's just [__] there's ever since
there was like I don't know if world
star was the first right
but anytime anything happens
phone's out baby phone's out
phones out now phone down Gotta Get It
gotta capture it everybody look at your
phone right now different angles
different perspectives different
perspectives
uh it's people stealing from Zoomies
glad we're not there anymore you see
that well actually it'd be kind of
iconic people are stealing Teddy fresh
because that would be great actually
that'd be really cool
this is wild this is so wild
yeah it's just like the group mentality
is really scary oh I mean that's a real
that's a real thing these people would
not be doing this I feel like
but if it was just that one because
teachers are out no rules it's a sub day
no phones right nobody's recording
every single person we're not recording
it guys don't send this to NYPD okay
driving away with people on oh I can't
show that one he drives away with people
straight from a zombie movie people are
on his van like 20 of them and they
start falling off and he doesn't slow
down to let them off either because I
think they're running for their lives
they start falling off dude
there it is
well we'll see what happens I mean
certainly not a great look for twitch
streamers
not a great look or I mean social media
stars in general I don't even think I
think it's beyond that yeah
yeah
this is not his fault
it's some his fault
your fault you know what I mean
default
yeah I mean it's his responsibility it's
his fan base he asked he invited them
out and it turned into a disaster oh
yeah imagine being a Taurus there from
like Japan like you know like what's
happening
yes
oh [__] you're all of a sudden just in
the middle of a riot with no explanation
all right let's talk about fousey I'm
ready had some time to compress now
what how old are you
did I talk about this at all I don't
think I've talked about it at all about
fousey no because if this happened over
the weekend it happened yeah there's a
couple yesterday right so I'm not going
to show any of the footage because one I
don't want to show the girl's face and
two
um
I don't think we need to see the footage
no definitely not I think I can just
talk about it if you want to see it it's
out there you know what I mean
so you know
I I poured over this footage I watched
all of it because I really wanted to
know what was happening
the allegation
okay well see here's what happened and
then I'll tell you about the allegation
so fousey
is in the airport
and there's a girl at the airport at the
bar
she's drinking
it looked to me like a stiff drink like
some kind of Long Island thing because
she was she seemed like
drunk he seemed like drunk when he sits
down next to her
and they start hitting it off they're
connecting you know everything's fine
everything's cool
the first thing that I was like hey
uh he says to the bartender hey get her
another drink
on me he doesn't ask her and she's
already like pretty drunk
so straight off the bat I was like but I
don't think that would have been a pro I
don't think that would have been problem
without the allegation that comes
afterwards
but I mean I guess it does matter in
context of the whole thing
um
so they're sitting there then they start
to get super flirty
uh they start touching each other
they're even kissing and hugging and
stuff he's got his hand on her thigh she
starts telling him
that she has a tattoo of another man's
name above her genitals because she was
sex trafficked
she said she was a uh lot lizard I'd
never heard that before apparently
that's like a prostitute that works at
truck stops
which seems quite seedy and disgusting
no offensive truck drivers
but probably the ones soliciting sex at
the
front the truck stop not like the yeah
most up and up dudes
so she starts being really vulnerable
with them and saying I was sex
trafficked I uh
I escaped from it she has kids she's
traveling to go see her two kids that
are living with her dad because she
can't take care of them
and she's working a minimum wage job 11
an hour she's like dead broke
she showed him she's like I have like a
hundred dollars for this whole weekend
with my kids it was very sad honestly I
I really felt for her
and the situation she's been through
and um
so then after that Foos is like yo I'm
going to give you money right now and he
gave her 300 bucks which was great
and then he's like chat if you guys want
to donate here's her cash up and then
the chat ended up donating like 2 500
bucks it was great she was crying it was
feel good I was happy for her genuinely
because like she's the type of person or
that like that money is very meaningful
for her and her and her you know her
kids
it was very nice
um after that though
I guess I don't know they started
bonding like
[__] was like well I'm used to be a sex
addict and
you know so I understand where you're
coming from and all that
and um there's a certain point soon
after that
with the money and the flirting and the
kissing
where he
he says hey come with me away from the
camera I want to talk to you
and then they walk off like I don't know
20 feet away from the camera but the
camera's still on though you can't hear
them but you can see them
and they're embracing each other they're
very close
they might be making out honestly I
watched this part very closely it was
hard to tell it's possible that they
weren't kissing it's possible they were
it was hard to tell but that doesn't
really matter with what happens next
because I feel like
again if it would have just ended
at the right time it would have been a
great story and everyone would have been
super happy for this girl
so they come back from embracing each
other potentially kit making out
they come back to the camera
and he tells the stream hey I'm gonna go
get her stuff from the convenience store
and stuff we're gonna go walk around
and so he turns the camera around
to the bartender
and it's on the bartender for
I don't remember the exact 10 20 minutes
maybe yeah something like that
an extended period of time
and then uh well the problem starts when
he comes back or I guess the problem
really starts when he's coming back I
think there's enough I think you know
there's enough moral questions about
making up with a girl
that drunk that fast and all that
uh
but he comes back and he goes
yo guys I can't hide it man we just had
sex in the bathroom
he's like yo guys I swear on my life we
just had sex in the bathroom
and it seems that he's being completely
completely genuine he said yeah I joined
the mile high club
which he's on the ground
was he in Denver
maybe well they anyway they were she
came back and she was like playing along
she's like oh yeah well we kind of did
you know it's only they were joking
around and then he goes um I guess he
starts looking at chat and he realizes
that people are like yo what the [__]
and then immediately he goes I'm kidding
you guys got pranked
you guys got pranked you guys uh and and
to me watching that I see a dude who's
humiliated
ashamed embarrassed and just got caught
and realizes how bad he [__] up
and he so so
he sits there for another 10 minutes
talking about how bad he feels and like
he can't get over he's like I'm such a
scumbag for doing this prank on you he's
like I'm such a scumbag for doing a
prank on you like he and it doesn't make
sense to have that immense amount of
guilt over a silly prank
so anyway
she basically when they come back I feel
like he's super standoffish
she was really
kind of you know into the moment I don't
know describe it but uh eventually he
was like yo you need to catch your
flight you're gonna miss it and she left
and he continued to talk about how bad
he felt about the prank
so
the Optics of this of course is that
he got he continued to get this girl
drunk who was already drunk when he
found out she was a former prostitute
gave her gave her a bunch of money and I
have to say uh a girl like this and I
don't know them personally but I've I've
watched a lot of interviews and
documentaries about how it affects these
people and I think when you're in
prostitution or sex trafficking like
that for so long
forced prostitution I should say
I don't I think she was like uh
she's being you know Human trafficked by
a pimp if I had to guess
um
is that when these people come out of
this really traumatic experience they
expect that men want sex from them
that they have to give men sex
in order to you know
keep their attention to keep their
interests it really I feel that this is
really a powerful force that these women
learn people learn when they're in this
really a traumatic situations like the
ones that she was in
and so it appeared
that he was
now that he gave her money she's gonna
like he just got her two twenty five
hundred dollars so she it's very
possible felt like she owes him now and
that's how she repays people that's in
her mind right that's the association so
they walk off
they go to the bathroom and have sex in
the men's bathroom uh is what fousey
said and then retracted
so it's really bad in terms of like what
happened
now fousey denies
that anything happened he maintains even
to me that
he tells me that it was just a prank
and obviously nobody believes that and I
told him that I said dude nobody's going
to believe that
nobody's going to believe that was just
a prank and frankly I am having a hard
time believing that like I went back and
I watched
his the part that for me that was really
compelling is when he comes back
and he's talking to the camera
and he says you know we had sex and then
he's like no no just kidding it's like
I feel like in my opinion you know I
mean it seems to me that
he did do that
that was I mean it's hard to interpret
any other way and I want to give him the
benefit of the doubt you know I mean I
do but I don't think I can
um
so I guess this this was blowing up
while he was on the flight and it
started Brewing into a huge huge thing
obviously
it was super super super [__] up
how that went down
um
and so my first thought and concern is
that I I know we have lots of
conversations about his mental health
and being Manic and potentially at times
during lows being um
suicidal by the way I see our the
podcast got disliked bombed by xqc fans
let's go one point nine thousand down
dude love you okay for the views oh dude
he did the worm on you
this was blowing through that's 20 2.5
000 down let's go kids
so
my initial thought was just like
some of you might disagree okay like I I
was concerned for his well-being
because I know and I've seen it before
how a situation like this can have a
toll on his mind
and I I I just wanted to make sure that
he's not I just want to make sure he's
okay
right that he's not gonna try to hurt
himself really genuinely that was my
first concern
so he actually called me
I talked to him he was on the plane
and he was like stressing out freaking
out about it obviously and my advice to
him which has always been I said dude
first of all you have to stop the Stream
you can't do it anymore you have to stop
it
you have to turn it off
and the next thing that you need to do
when you get there when you're in a
comfortable place is just
or maybe I don't know take some time to
digest what's happening but you need to
come out and make it sincere and
completely honest statement about what
happened and what what you're doing
about it and I told him dude you need to
when you get there you need to see a
therapist like immediately like I want
you talking to somebody and he he and to
his credit he was doing that
so my my first priority in in this whole
situation was just to make sure that
he's gonna go see a therapist that he's
not you know what I mean that he's gonna
not slip into like a total manic Frenzy
I've seen people go I had an
ex-girlfriend when she she went Matic
she would like end out in a grassy field
naked thinking aliens were abducting her
like you get that divorce from reality
during manic episodes
at least her
at least with her that was my my
girlfriend was bipolar
so that was my experience with her
so um
that was basically yeah I mean that was
basically
my conversations with them I was just
like dude you got to slow down go see
therapist make sure that like look after
your mind and then you need to come back
and talk honestly about what happened
and um
I'm not really sure what else to say
about it I mean I saw the statement when
he landed
and again
in the statement he maintains that
nothing happened
that it was just a prank
but like I I again I do want I want to
give the benefit of the doubt right I do
but I I frankly don't I don't believe
him
I don't believe him and I told him that
I said I don't believe you and nobody's
going to believe you like don't even try
that excuse
so I don't know he didn't take my
I guess he didn't take my advice in that
situation but
who know I mean that's he maintains
nothing happened I don't know
am I saying as he stayed offline since
all this went down his bound so so he
came home he did a stream talking about
it
which was kind of
not the best because I felt he I think
he just fell short by not
being super honest and open about what
happened
but
he he talked to the people and then he
said I'm ending the Stream
uh to go get help
and take some time so that is good
and then I guess yesterday he got banned
on um
you got banned on Twitch and I did find
out for seven days
and it was nothing related to this
interestingly I guess he said the f slur
earlier that day
or no it was right after the drama
started people were giving him [__] and
he was blocking him and I saw that clip
he's like I would call you an f word but
I don't use that word anymore he said
the word though and so he got banned for
a week for that and that's bad enough
obviously
well one thing I told him honestly was I
I think you need to really consider
if
this kind of life is right for you
because
it only took like a month
for it to go off the rails and everybody
your family and you were telling
yourself
to be cool don't [__] it up and it only
took a month
for this to go completely sideways bad
and so I'm like dude I don't know if
this is
I don't know if this is the right out
for this Biz you know I just I just I
don't know that this is your path to
happiness
I don't think that it's good for you
and you need to go and meditate and
think about every you need to really
think about if this is something
that you should continue pursuing
you know he he was ready to accept his
life as like a uh you know
he was talking about on the podcast he
was ready to drive an Uber
and I just think that like he has some
inclinations in his mind
whatever it is if it's bipolar or many
whatever it is
that the attention he gets just it sends
him off the rails
so I encourage them to strongly think
about
kind of
not coming back or deciding I'm not
saying not coming back because I do
think he should and I think he will come
and talk about it more about what
happened
but to potentially consider that this is
not the right profession for him
you know what I mean it just may not be
just doesn't seem to be good for you or
anybody
right
and it's a hard pill to swallow frankly
because he was making a lot of money he
was doing great who's getting attention
he felt like he's back on top of the
world but honestly what's it all worth
when
it takes you a month to completely
destroy it all you know
um
right I don't know so that was my
encouragement just to stay Tristan Tate
tweeted that Ethan owned xqc
wait they have beef
Christian Tate is running for Ethan
Klein he was responding to a Jake
uh Jake sucky tweet
Jake sucky that was silky h3nic debate
on react content ends in them both just
insulting each other and X doing the
worm I wouldn't say I don't actually
owned SUV okay Tate Brothers I've always
been a big fan of the team okay that's
not let's not go that far I'm kidding
you belong in jail you freak but I'll
take the dubs where I can
I'll take the I love the idea of Tristan
Tate on sitting at home ready to go to
prison for life and he's watching this
debate
watching xqc and H3 podcast debate I
know I don't know that this is a fair
assessment of what on react content ends
in them both just insulting each other
um um yeah not the best headline I don't
think we were both equally
sir did you call him any names
he called you a [__] idiot and said
you lick balls and I mean the thing that
kept tilting was I said he's a Content
Thief that's just mean but I felt like
that was just kind of my opinion about
the situation yeah all right I wasn't
saying that to be incendiary
okay take it Tristan Tate he's the cool
one he's always been the cool brother
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm doing [__]
here I'm doing [__] good job it's a joke
you guys it's a joke
it's a joke stop it you're done you're
done kid
um you ain't cut out for this biz
so yeah I mean in short
I just really wanted to make sure he's
okay and that nothing more bad happens
that would be the worst and that was my
ultimate concern
so and that is still my concern you know
what I mean
so I just wanted I said please get help
take time away and just think deeply and
soberly about
if this is the right
field for you
and um you say soberly do you think he
relapsed
well I don't I was just thinking because
he said the last time he was having an
existential crisis he went dead
ayahuasca
and I'm thinking like I don't really
think that is the proper way to reflect
and make yeah and to reflect on your
life and your behavior sober I think
sober is the way to do that
so I was just emphasizing that I think
he needs to be sober
and not go and do Ayahuasca or something
you know what I mean
um
but he's assured me that all that stuff
is happening he's talked with this
shrink
he's still on his meds he's with his
family and that's all very good
um
obviously the what happened to the girl
allegedly again he denies it I don't
believe him frankly I I just I can't lie
about that I just don't I feel sick
about it I watched the footage I felt so
sick about it it was so inspiring yeah I
actually well people are wanting me to
say something I do want to say something
but at the same time I don't want to
Dogpile him too much that's what I'm
afraid I'm worried of him that's it
that's what possibly harming himself but
I was on a road trip I was coming back
from Arizona at the time and I was live
streaming and everyone was coming into
my chat and telling me
to checking up call fuzzi he's he's this
is happening and I was like I'm gonna
wait till I go home and see see it for
myself I went home and I couldn't
believe what I was watching it was uh it
was it was really hard to watch
I know he yeah it was hard to watch and
it was like it was so close to being a
good wholesome exchange yeah it was so
close
you know and this girl she was so
vulnerable
she was so vulnerable yeah I'm very
drunk very drunk and very vulnerable
with her
with the way she was talking and being
so upfront with him she was being super
flirty with them yeah and and like we're
too drunk to give to consent
she was all yeah when she went a good
way to finishing the drink he bought her
too yeah she could not have consented to
anything unfortunately so
you know if he's yeah and I mean they
just met it's yeah
like literally just met
and uh so yeah I mean obviously
like Amy said I really don't want to
Dogpile on him I want him to get better
I think he can get better and I think
he will and that's what he should focus
on you know what I mean
and uh but but it was very I don't want
to also downplay what happened which was
very bad right
yeah he had a lot of people rooting on
him so you know it's uh it's tough
because there's no defending what
happened so
yeah
and so uh again he says nothing happened
but I I feel like that just makes him
look silly right to be honest
well even what we did see you know what
I mean like that's enough right the
flirting the hand on the knee the making
I don't know that yeah
um
yeah it's it's you know I mean
sucks
but
I mean I do think
yeah
I wonder
I I want I'm afraid that girl's gonna
feel so bad now they exchange Instagrams
and I'm afraid I don't want her to also
if they feel like it's her fault all
this thing too
he did at some point mention her
bringing her back on stream which is not
a good idea definitely don't do that if
you're one that is not a good idea it's
not going to make anything better
well he
okay I don't wanna I don't wanna
uh guess too much about what's what what
he would do about with that content but
yeah he got banned for seven days I told
him dude it's a blessing you need this
time
he
I mean listen I don't he messaged me
this morning he says my life is over
he just sent me
whatever I don't know
um
so I mean I don't know what to say about
it really I just hope that like he takes
the time to really focus on what's
important and what's better and if he
can be totally honest and I think that's
the beginning of healing I mean he has
he he's been very open with his sex
addiction
and uh
obviously that's not an excuse by any
means
but it is clear it doesn't seem like
something that he's on top of
so I mean that that's that's all you
know that's all I really can say about
that I don't know if you guys have any
questions or comments
but like I am in contact with them if
you guys are wondering
because some I I can see a lot of y'all
being like
not a lot but I see the argument of like
why are you sympathizing with fousey and
not the victim
which you know I get I guess it is
confusing but I'm I'm staying in touch
with them because I care about what
happens to him
you know it's funny that you said you
had an ex that had bipolar issues
because last night when you know we were
messaging about this I I told Lena I had
a feeling that she did because I had an
ex as well who was like this and that's
why I'm able to recognize it and like
we're not saying that uh fousey is the
victim obviously but we at least me and
I could identify that uh
it's it's very dangerous for him to be
in the mindset he's in so
yeah I just want to make sure he doesn't
do anything
right and it seems that he's doing the
right things right now to take care of
himself yeah
so you know in that sense I just want
him to be okay
and I encourage him that there is room
for growth
and there is room for there is another
life beyond
Beyond streaming
where you can be happy and fulfilled and
honest like that there is there is
always that hope and you will achieve
that you will
that's it and obviously my heart goes
out to the girl I mean I I don't know
much about her other than I mean we just
saw her for that like 20 to 30 minutes
span
it seems by all accounts really sweet
and somebody who's been through so much
in her life man and I just hope that
I just hope that he's um
I hope that she's okay you know I hope
that this doesn't me too [__] her up too
much
that's it
you know what I mean
I feel like just ganging up on him and
dog piling and piling it on is not the
right move right now
I don't know
maybe it's not right but that's how I
feel
my guy my gut
I don't know what to say
I'm I'm on the girls side somebody said
you're not taking that I'm on the girl's
side
I just don't want fousey to it's a very
fragile situation make any any more
mistakes yeah
that's what it is
he uh responded to drama alert oh great
he's been mentioning me a lot which
is a little uncomfy but
I'm you know I mean I know how bad you
want the capitalize in this because I'm
not friends with H3 but I got banned for
using the F slur
yeah keemstar has been going ham on this
by the way
like ham
but whatever
uh that's it I mean I don't know what
else there is to say about it
is there anything else I don't know
my guy my guy
is that it
interesting just shout out Tristan tape
[__] Legend I'm kidding I'm kidding
I'm kidding somebody here just to put
things back in perspective on the
Tristan thing
somebody sent me this this is his uh
feed back to back
remember the video about what make up
your mind dude Justin Tatum wage
three is more in jail than him oh that's
the one we watched right that's the one
that we watched that he doesn't work out
so he repost that and then next message
you had to balance it out I guess listen
both can be true I love that for him
he's a man of multiple Minds he's the
middle path as as uh Siddhartha the
Buddha told us to walk all right
you have any thoughts Olivia uh I don't
know
I asked because for the for the
women's voice if if you have anything to
add uh
I just I feel sick about it
it was
it was pretty disturbing to watch
um
that's honestly
that's fine you don't have to that's it
I mean yeah yeah you don't have to say
that's enough
enough to say about it
I mean I I hope that he's okay I hope
that she's okay
dude you know what's crazy
kick paid 100 million for that [__]
guy
he brings the views dude
he brings the views
dude they got ripped off man
by the way again he hasn't cambled on on
Kick but do you think he will someday
gamble on Kick probably probably I mean
he is a self-admitted gambling addict
and he works for a company that runs a
casino
hard to
yeah he probably will say that then but
it wouldn't happen if you don't then you
know standing apology to you
prove me wrong
uh let's see anything else I mean I
guess that's foreign
we're at three hours 22 minutes right
now I'm looking for a goddamn palette
cleanser
guys ask xqc who is Mr chair
some people do that though
oh [__] another paid actor YouTuber I
did a thing as another paid actor by xqc
like every single time
I think he's a good guy exactly you see
what's happening he's hedging his Bat
because he does he doesn't [__] like
what he did but because he's this huge
creator with this rabid fan base he
knows he it they can make his life hell
for simply asking him not to steal his
[__] that's what just happened
um
I think please don't [__] ruin my
life
every single time I release a video he
will do a react and release a react
Within four or five hours and he doesn't
say anything it's just him watching the
video and then he pause and goes how do
you do that and then unpause what the
heck what is going on same thumbnail
same title as well if that's not meant
to siphon off views I don't know what is
that's so true and then his video
dude this guy's a hack
how much you pay him Ethan dude me
listen the details of me and I did it
things
uh contractual obligations is none of
your business
I'm making it my business
I was infusing that day I'm like you
Jeff this guy's Awesome by the way his
content is crazy he's the man he's also
jacked bro yeah he was in the first
Creator Clash he's insanely jacked right
he just he like makes like kind of goofy
little mentions in his his backyard he
does gadgets that makes it sound like
I'm denigrating him yeah like a goofy
little things yeah I'm sorry I didn't
mean it like that yeah he makes really
cool little things in his back he does
the inventions he does the thing he does
the thing yeah okay yeah yeah he's the
guy he's the guy I'm thinking of yeah
his videos are very fun people are
wondering if potentially and this is a
good theory what if Vince was
throast
hmm
what if whoa
look away 300 000 people from watching
my video whoa there it is I mean what do
you what more do you want okay so here's
another guy
who's outright saying it and also he's
basically saying between the lines that
he's scared to even put this out there
in The Ether the ethernet
there it is man I mean what the [__]
more do you want just admit you're wrong
you gotta change got to
right
thank you guys keep these coming by the
way because this is all really good
paid actors
by the end of the week we're gonna have
a whole goddamn troop of paid actors
they'll be able to put on a play called
the downfall of xqc
by all the paid actors
produced and directed by Ethan Klein
coming to Broadway soon performed by
Colleen Ballinger is the lead and uh uh
who's the Colleen plays execution who
plays SpongeBob and Ethan Slater and
Ethan Slater as uh me yes yes and it's
just entertainment too listen guys yes
it's true that uh I wholesale steal
people's videos and upload it straight
to my channel but hey every nobody's
having fun
and fun there's nobody to lose
planing oh he's just
there
this Vince guy is a total paid actor
there's no victims
the whole course goes we are
they're all paid actors
actually the one he did too I did a
thing
how's that even possible
his is shorter
same time let me pull this up just to
show you what a [__] piece of [__] he
is
here's the guy who says I don't like
when he does this straight up okay so
we're not even gonna debate it
how many pressure washers does it take
to fly
here's him concept about myself many
times right he his channel is great
here is xqc with his face
same [__] thumbnail
how many pressure washers does it take
to fly
the same runtime dude I have less good
theory negative run time yeah I have a
good theory go ahead he probably skipped
the ad
in the video because it's boring oh
that'd be crazy
yeah the only possibly boring part of
the video you skip that [__] I think he
100 did that because why would he watch
that oh my God
that's funny so not so now you've
actually
gone out of your way to essentially it's
almost like erasing a watermark to the
sense he's cutting out his means of
profit yeah
the company paid him
to make this video and good for him for
making money honey did actually friend
of the show
Honey and you cut well before I before I
accuse him let's make sure you know what
I mean yeah I might be talking out of my
ass here and I don't want to do that
can you link me that one I am seeing I
saw people in the chat say the same
thing though that that's why I mean it
makes so much sense yeah
by the way I'll say that so the uh the
hassanabi huge channel that you were
going talking about earlier that had
already re-upload the video
um they had uh
what our mod confirmed that that
actually was the hasanabi capital 2
channel from last week's leftovers
so they changed the name of the channel
probably because we talked about it did
anyone find out how to do the dmca well
I'm leading to that the video I was
going through to do it uh they privated
it oh good
there's another one too
I'm sure there's going to be several so
yeah I I did find um yeah YouTube It's
they just have a submission form to
submit
I was going to do it and the video
doesn't exist anymore so wait there was
another one though
uh yeah if you send me let's pop them
there let's bop them right now Bap them
put it out there this is [__] I'm
[__] sick of these leeches man
you actually got what I was referring to
absolutely I bought
a box remember those yeah I'm all about
Bob Pitts bro oh thanks for the [__]
dude so did they just I guess or bop it
still around I've seen one recently I
feel like I want to play right now
honestly spin it push someone find the
link to that other upload though so we
can dmca Hasbro game
if uh somebody wants to link it to me I
will go ahead and take care of that
Hasbro gaming bop it looks a little
different but the principal's the same
they're still out there
shout out Hasbro shout out to Hasbro
Corporation
foreign
is anyone getting that link
yeah I've been working on it
sorry I'm just answering I'm doing high
level uh imagine I had a video playing
right now is there anything hey guys
talk to Mr chair for a minute
here I'll uh I'll vamp
um
just got a 20 uh 20 Australian dollar
donation from t
en hey Ethan big fan for years and it's
great to see you looking so healthy
thank you so much love from Australia
thanks Hayden shout out Hayden
what do you have a
all the balloons
like a one year birthday so at the
moment I'm actually not seeing
I'm seeing uh ours and then here's one
of I guess Destiny watching it which is
fine it's only a five minute clip
xqc asked Destiny for help moments
before Ethan Klein debate that's awesome
should I watch that no it did skip that
by the way but again and then the other
one is him posting his elves which is do
you want me to sit here and listen to
you see we already watched that but I
love that and then here is um
oh you got the so he does skip that he
does skip that and you know it's the
worst part it's honey
yeah I know they're friends of the show
we love hunting by the way here I am by
the way starring in uh coming to
Broadway this is Ethan uh someone I
forget his name the dude plays SpongeBob
Ethan Klein baby
wow yeah jump scared
I mean
he looks right on those Stars Jesus no
offense brother
just it's just jarring I'm not saying
anything else about it's just a little
jarring it feels just it's just a little
joke like a sudden jolt you know what he
looks like hold on this is exactly what
he looks like
what do you got oh you think so oh okay
isn't that a classic Trump insult who's
he calling the mad all pretty Newman uh
who was uh he bootage Edge yes which so
so so good
once again doesn't mess with those
although some you know what he there was
a major Miss I saw somebody else point
this out this past weekend who was it he
one of the people that he's running
against he's calling him little the way
that he called Marco Rubio oh there's a
new little in town it's a new little
and I'm sorry oh it's Mike Pence that's
right it was like little Mike Pence it's
like
recycled you're recycling dude come on
there's got to be something for better
there's so many
like yeah I was gonna say weird Mike
yeah like creeping like wearing my
creepy mic like
he's creepy man yeah he's bizarre so I
don't actually did you guys find any I'm
not seeing any uh I haven't been able to
find another I mean I guess we'll if we
if one pops up and there's well that's
great I guess they got the message yeah
if you guys see any let us know I'm
gonna [__] bop them they're all
getting bopped bop it and I'm just
talking about these scum
uh pretending to represent Hassan
channels or other streamers and it's
just a wholesale re-uploading yeah not
[__] with anything else all right
well that's the show guys thank you for
being here
thank you for joining me on this debate
I know a lot of people didn't want it to
happen
I was almost close to canceling it
well are you glad we did it now Dan I'm
I'm fine it went fine
I was close to canceling it but last
night I felt like I had enough put
together
sure well I I it was after you got that
message from uh from a paid actor yeah
you were like you know
which Fair yeah because before that it's
all just theoretical [__] right
exactly
I liked how he's like this video had a
85 decrease in views which proves I
helped it
because you don't understand stats was
that his point because that's a silly
point I I feel like we were
misunderstanding his point was that you
can't know because it's just one data
set and videos naturally get less views
I that's all over time right that was
what I was kind of of the one data point
we have it does not help you yeah you
know it's unfortunate because I think
that there probably is an interesting
conversation to have about that and xqc
just isn't the guy
you know right he's the he's the big
offender right now though so because
like I I could tell him maybe he was
getting these talking points from
somebody that was helping him prep or
whatever but right maybe
you should just be German not that guy
you know what I mean maybe not a bad guy
explain to me why why because personally
I'm not here to joustin and Dick compare
I genuinely am here to have a
conversation and talk about the issue I
want to know
yeah anyway another time thank you guys
I hope you all have a uh fantastic
evening
I'm doing Howie's podcast tomorrow right
and and by the way it's live coming up
so that wait what he says it's their
first live show
he's like I said I said how you're going
to regret that yeah
because they always cut stuff from my
interview
true
but they want to go live hey well that's
interesting huh they'll be the first
unfortunately that means that you will
not be doing your stream tomorrow is it
is one of God well I didn't do it last
week I do want to do it so let's see my
my podcast with Howie's at two so maybe
I'll do it at a little pre 12. yeah do a
little pre-show from 12 to 1 30. ish
maybe a little I'll have to leave a
little early on how far you gotta go
yeah so yeah tomorrow I'll do the the
members for at 12. well that's great all
right so member stream at 12 tomorrow
and then I guess check out catch me on
Howard on uh Howie Mandel does stuff I'm
about to [__] can't get his show done
Howie Mandel does a thing 12.
people are saying yeah you're going to
be going live with no button well I mean
to be fair you do you do do that on your
your homes yeah and I always I'm look
where's the button no I maybe we
shouldn't do it live now I'm scared
you're good I'm gonna just be like I get
to think about everything I say
it's gonna be a really important
what to think about what you nobody like
it's gonna be a thank you dude but it's
gonna be like this I
really think but nothing happens
whatever it's not that funny all right
guys see you tomorrow okay on Wednesday
a fantastic week love you all
take care
[Music]